foreign
Ty expert course by simply learn in this
video we will discuss what is chat GPT
gpt4 and working of chat GPD moving
ahead with the course we will see the
use of chat Jeopardy in various domain
and Hands-On demo to use jet GPT for SEO
digital marketing and more however we
will share the best tips and tricks of
chat jpd but before we begin consider
subscribing to our Channel hit the Bell
icon to never miss any update from
Simply learn on that note we present you
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning elevate your professional
journey by enrolling in this Ai and ml
course presented through a partnership
between Purdue University and IBM
acquire sought after abilities like
machine learning deep learning natural
language processing computer vision
reinforcement learning generative AI
prompt engineering chat Jeopardy and a
multitude of others that are in high
demand learn generative ai explainable
ai chat GPT machine learning algorithms
supervised and unsupervised learning and
much more hurry up and enroll Now find
the complete course details from the
link mentioned in the description box
below so without any further Ado let's
begin with chat GPT expert course that
covers all the uses with demonstration
on how chat Jeopardy is helpful in
various domains now over to our tutors
hey hey I'm Sharia Jalil I live in
Ontario Canada I have been in I.T sector
for the past 20 years I recently took
the professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning the course has changed the way
I look at things and helped me back some
amazing freelance projects I started my
career in 1999 and over the years I have
worked with many companies my last tenor
was with IBM Canada my aim was to
restart my carrier and learn something
that would help accelerate my career
I thought artificial intelligence can
make me Future Ready
the course in artificial intelligence
and machine learning is provided by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
course I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome the quality of
interaction within the course was simply
amazing course faculty was also very
experienced and knowledgeable
after the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects also I
am planning to start an AI based startup
with my friend where I feel that the
learning from the course to be very
helpful I am really delighted and happy
in my free time I try to create
meaningful content on YouTube and I talk
about new technologies and what kind of
courses professionals should be taking
along with many other topic I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
compromise you should always learn from
the band meet John a talented programmer
who is looking to start a company that
used his personally developed mobile
application to connect restaurants and
customers for booking and reservations
even though the app was ready John had
difficulty getting together a team for
his startup meeting separate people for
sales marketing programming content
creation and customer support
hiring reliable Manpower while being
strict with his budget was getting
difficult
he reached out to his friend Ryan who
said John could start his company
without hiring any new people thanks to
just a single AI based tool John
couldn't believe it which led Ryan to
introduce chat gbt the Revolutionary AI
chatbot being developed by open AI it is
a state-of-the-art natural language
processing or NLP model that uses a
neural network architecture to provide
responses
this means that the chat GPT bot can
answer questions without being
explicitly told what the answer is using
its own intellect unlike previous AI
chat Bots
so how does chat GPT help John in
filling out his team
regarding sales chat GPT can provide
full-fledged sales pitches based on the
correct prompts it can provide tips on
how to pitch your product businesses
removing the need for sales training
completely customized to your
requirements and your prompts if you
don't like some things about the
response you can ask for certain changes
and the chat bot will make sure they are
done when it comes to marketing chat EPT
can provide efficient marketing
strategies which can help new
entrepreneurs learn how to Market their
products to prospective clients it can
provide trending keywords that marketers
can use for SEO purposes while providing
ad copies for your website and blog
speaking of websites since John can do a
lot of the heavy lifting and programming
chat GPT can help proofread the code and
help out when looking for bugs to fix
apart from basic bug fixing it can also
provide sample code structures for
different programming languages allowing
John to focus more on improving core
functionality and workflow rather than
fixing basic code errors
websites and blogs content is very
helpful in gathering potential customer
leads
the Revolutionary bot can provide
full-length blog posts with near perfect
fast accuracy in seconds allowing
further customization like choosing the
length of the subject matter to the
complexity of language
for John's customer support the bot can
draft complete customer service emails
based on the situation saving time and
resources
the tone of the message can be changed
to reflect the nature of the message
creating an efficient alternative for
call centers professionals
John was left speechless seeing this
level of Versatility from chat GPT and
wanted to implement it right away
however Ryan made sure John knew about
some drawbacks of the chat bot before
getting started
since the bot is trained mostly on data
up to 2021 many of the newer events May
still need to be discovered by chat GPT
even basic stuff like asking about the
current date and time is beyond its
scope much like the limited
understanding of context despite
providing near lifelike solutions to
certain problems even the accuracy of
many responses can be questioned since
the AI model is still learning and being
developed there is a section of the
public that believes the Revolutionary
tool can one day replace Google search
but that day seems far-fetched so far
because of the variety of issues people
keep running into and using chat GPT
however chat GPT poses a lot of promise
for the future of AI from full-skilled
automated divisions and organizations to
serving as the perfect digital assistant
open AI is creating a bot for the future
aimed at solving the problems of today
with the tools of Tomorrow the ability
to carry out a myriad of tasks with
minimum Manpower will boost productivity
at organizations in every sector thanks
to the Revolutionary chat GPT so how do
you think chat GPT will benefit your
daily life are you looking forward to
using the bot regularly for work or
personal life let us know your thoughts
in the comments below
meet John a software developer John
develops a program and now he realizes
the program is surrounded by a lot of
bugs
John starts exploring a solution
he surfs through the internet checks
programmer communities
doubting every step of the way John
feels his problem is not solved
desperate to find the solution John
meets his friend Adam
comes up with an idea of an artificially
intelligent and practical solution
called the chat GPT
Adam says chat GPT has the caliber to
systematically resolve all the bugs with
an elaborate explanation for every step
it makes
chat GPT is an AI trained model that
works in a conversational way
developed by open AI
fascinated by hearing this John asks
Adam to explain him in detail after Adam
explains that GPT AKA generative
retraining Transformer has come a long
way
before the introduction of GPT natural
language processing used to deal with a
specific task with large amounts of data
GPT was first released in 2018 which
contained 117 million parameters
GPT gpt2 and gpt3 each one is stronger
than the one before it
the main reason why GPT received little
attention was that it was more of an
idea or task than a finished product
but after the introduction of gpt2 it
gained a lot of attention as it could
accurately predict the word that would
begin a text then they introduced gpt3
which is a strong language model
achieving translation question answering
and Performing three-digit arithmetic
[Music]
at GPT Stands Tall compared to all other
achievements of open AI so how does it
work chat gbt uses deep learning
techniques to generate human-like text
it is based on the machine learning
model derived from the class called the
large language model
chat GPT is a byproduct of instruct GPT
instruct GPT introduced a strategy for
integrating human feedback into the
training process to match model outputs
this Innovative technology made chat GPT
exceptional
it is trained on the massive data sets
of text from the internet and learns
from the patterns and relationships
between words and phrases
it responds to a prompt by determining
the next word based on the context then
repeats the process until a stop
condition is met
as a result chatgpt can produce various
logical responses to various queries and
prompts
the most important components of chat
GPT are the Transformer model and
language model coming to the Transformer
model it is a neural network
architecture designed to process
sequential data it consists of multiple
layers of self-attention and a feed
forward Network
after the Transformer model has
processed the input a decoder generates
the output
the decoder uses the context provided by
the encoder to generate the response
the model is trained using unsupervised
learning and fine-tune on specific tasks
using supervised learning for successful
completion of tasks it needs pre-trained
data the model first encodes the input
text then converts it to a numerical
representation which can be processed by
the model's neural network
this encoding is done using the embedded
layer that Maps the work
then comes the language model
chat GPT is trained as a language model
trained to predict the next word in a
sequence given the previous words
the language model intends to produce
rational consistent and meaningful
output the pre-trained chat GPT can be
tuned for a specific task
so chatgpt passes a fine tuning test by
answering questions generating text
summaries or generating text in response
to a query
overall chat GPT is a powerful language
model with a combination of techniques
like deep learning machine learning
neural networks and natural language
processing
in chat GPT change a wide variety of
business tasks John asked
chat GPT possesses the ability to
automate content creation on social
media create chatbot and e-commerce
sites provide medical assistance by
acting as a symptom checker write code
and assist a developer thus chatgpt can
change the working of every industry now
John can resolve any coding issue
without looking into any other resources
but like any other technology chatgpt
comes with a few limitations that can be
its Achilles heel
chat GPT is capable of developing
content up to 2021
it finds difficulty in providing logical
reasoning in certain situations and also
chatgpt lags and translation
summarization and sometimes question
answering
but above all chat GPT has shown
remarkable ability by providing accurate
answers flawlessly in a creative way in
very short periods of time
whether your Tech Enthusiast a expert or
just curious about the new and exciting
development you won't want to miss this
discussion about the latest AI sensation
I'm talking about chat gbd a highly
Advanced language model based on gpt3
technology developed by open AI chat GPT
is a state of art language generation AI
model that has captured the attention of
millions of people around the world it
has been trained on a massive data set
of text Data making it one of the most
largest language models to date but do
you know a new version of GPD is coming
up it's called gpt4 and it will support
up to 1 trillion parameters compared to
175 billion parameters of gpt3 now you
might be wondering what are these
parameters so what it means when a user
sends a query to the New Year version of
stat GPT then it will process that query
with all 1 trillion parameters to
deliver a correct and suitable response
isn't it mind-blowing not only that GPT
4 will have more applications than its
predecessor gpt3 the gpt3 has various
applications like text generation Tech
summarization automated content
generation application and is also being
used by various companies like viable
Fable studio and algolia aside from its
remarkable language handling ability
gpt4 has the possibility of being
utilized for additional functions such
as generating images and videos this is
due to the fact gpt4 is constructed
using the Transformer architecture which
has demonstrated Effectiveness in
multiple machine learning assignments
including computer vision psychologist
and cognitive scientist Gary marker said
that he can guarantee that GPT 4 will
blow the minds He also mentioned that
gpt4 will totally Eclipse chair gbt as
it has more parameters and is being
trained with more data however the CEO
Sam Altman debunks false information
surrounding the company's upcoming chat
gpt4 Orman said that he did not have an
actual AGI that is an artificial general
intelligence that could travel humans in
learning and existence
the release of chat GPT and other AI
powered chatbots had has a major impact
on Google search pieces with the New
York Times reporting that it prompted
Google's management to declare State
emergency referred to as code red gpt4
with its improved complexity and quicker
response time has the potential to
enhance communication by making it more
natural and accurate for instance short
sentence responses from a chat board can
reduce the likelihood of people clicking
on ads this AI technology could bring
about a major transformation in the
economy Google employees have been
assigned the task of developing AI
products with gpt4 that can match the
capability of gpt3 such as its
capability of generating art music and
other visuals that openai is currently
capable of Microsoft has invested 3
billion dollars into the open Ai and is
reportedly in discussion to invest an
additional 10 billion as deported by the
New York Times the paper also stated
that the release of gpt4 is expected to
take place in the first quarter of 2012
3 Matt McLovin a venture capitalist with
knowledge of GPT 4 hinted that the new
system May possess is multimodal
capabilities which refers to the
capability of functioning in various
modes such as text images and songs the
gpt4 chatbot built using Microsoft
extensive data center network has the
potential to be similar to charge GPT
generating only text or it could be
incorporate both text and images however
Sam Altman has cautioned not to set
expectations too high so at this point
it is difficult to say with certainty
what gpt4 will look like and what it
will be capable of so what do you think
about chat gbt4 do let us know in the
comment section below so we'll start
with the first trip that is change your
dashboard appearance so for that we'll
move to chair GPD and you could change
the desktop appearance for Dash to code
appearance of chat Jeopardy you can
customize your dashboard by going to
settings and choosing a new theme or
layout so for settings
we will go here and in general you can
just select the theme that is light you
can change it to dark system theme or
light theme so these are the options you
can use to change your dashboard
appearance so this can help you create a
more comfortable and personalized
working environment for example you can
change the color scheme and you can also
change the font size also and you can
generally change the font size by just
zooming in the window
and the second tip we have is switch on
beta features so we have moved back to
charge repeating and here you can see
the beta features so for that we'll go
in settings and data that is custom
instructions try a new feature that lets
you share anything you would like charge
gbd to consider closets responses so we
have switched on these beta features the
plugins try a version of chat Jeopardy
that knows when and how to use
third-party plugins that you enable the
code interpreter that is a version of
child Tubidy that knows how to write and
execute python code and can work with
file uploads so asking for help with
data analysis image conversions or
editing a code file and these files not
persist Beyond a single session so these
are the plugins or the beta features
that we have turned on and we are using
them and in chat gbt4 gbt4 you could see
that is code interpreter beta and the
plugins beta they both are available for
us so this was the second tip that is
switch on the beta features and you can
use them that is you can toggle on beta
features to try out new and experimental
features if you like trying out new
features you can switch on beta features
there are experimental features that are
still being tested keep in mind that
they might not always work perfectly and
the next is change the tone of your
writing that is you can ask chat GPT can
you rewrite any sentence in a more
formal way so now we will ask a prompt
to check GPT that is can you rewrite
this in a more formal tone and what we
can ask is that could be hey how are you
okay so we will ask this so you could
see that the child CPT has changed the
tone of the sentence or the imperative
you were asking that is hey how are you
now greetings how do you find yourself
today so this is a more formal tone and
you can ask chargpt for more such
responses that is give me more such
responses
so you can change the tone of the
sentence that is you could give any
sentence or any imperative or any
language to chat GPT and you can ask for
any tone that could be emotional that
could be funny tone or that could be
sarcastic tone so chat Jeopardy would
reply with the particular tone
so this was our third tip and now moving
on we'll see the fourth tip that is use
chat GPT for quick learning so you can
ask can you explain the basics of
anything that could be the simple
biology Concepts the solar system and
you can use charge apt for quick
learning that is for instance you could
ask any prompt
that is here we will ask chargpt that
teach me
how to write
hello world in Python
so you can see that Jupiter responded
that is showed writing a hello world
program in Python is quite
straightforward due to python Simplicity
and here's how you can do it that is
print hello world and in this code it
has given you some sentences so you can
just read them and understand how the
code works that is print is a built-in
python function that outputs specified
information to the screen then the text
that is hello world that is an inverted
commas is a string which is a type of
data representing text then the
parenthesis that are used to include the
arguments of the function so when you
run this program it will give the output
of the text that is hello world to the
console so this is the fourth tip and
moving on now we have our fifth tip that
is view the plugin store so now chat GPT
has many plugins that is we will create
a new chat and in gbt4 you could just
click on plugins So currently no plugins
are enabled and this is the plugin store
so the developers are developing plugins
so you could use them and be more
productive and add more features to the
chat repeating so you could see that is
aipdf that is super fast interactive
chats with PDFs of any site complete
with page references for fact checking
ask your PDF chat with PDF Expedia
notable link reader so these are the
plugins that you could use
and this comes with the gpt4 version
that is the paid version
so you could enable any plugin and you
can write any prompt and the chat GPT
will respond to it now moving on to the
next step
that is tip 6 use the web browsing
feature so with gpt4 and with the beta
versions you get a feature to search
with Bing or to browse with bank that is
not available for my account or for my
area so this is the new tip you can use
it if you have the paid version and if
you are accessible for the beta version
of browsing with pink so this was our
next tip and moving on we will see our
seventh tip that is templateize useful
prompts so you can ask can you create a
10 minute full body workout using some
kind of dumbbells or a barbell roll and
save this pump for future use you can
also templateize useful prompts for
instance you can also ask can you create
a menu or to-do list and save this
prompt for future use so we'll see a
quick example that would be
creator
10 minute
full body workout and that would be
using so you could see that the chat
Jeopardy has given us a templatized
routine so as a quick high intensity
power workout that you can complete in
about 10 minutes that is bubble
deadlifts and bubble squats bubble
overhead press bubble rules verbal bench
press so for that you also need to have
bench press also and the notice remember
the key to this workout is intensity and
form not necessarily the paid used okay
so this is how you can templateize
useful prompts
and moving on the next step we have is
summarize text that is you can paste a
long article and ask Chad jpt to convert
it or summarize in few sentences for
example you can paste a long arcade
article so I will show you how we can do
that we will just search for something
articles
so we'll
use any article we'll just copy it and
give this to chat Jeopardy that is to
paste it
and ask it can you
summarize this article
five sentences
so you know that this prompt will just
summarize the whole article into five
sentences and this is the feature of
charge apt to summarize anything and in
a very concise manner and this was our
tap eight and moving on
the next step we have is analyze your
writing pattern
that is can you you can ask chargpt can
you analyze my writing style and
generate a paragraph by making it that
is you can give it any text or chat that
you have done you can just copy that
chat and give that as a prompt to chat
GPT and you can then write a prompt that
can you analyze my writing style and
generate a paragraph by making it on any
topic so the child chapter will analyze
your writing pattern and will mimic your
style and you can also ask it to act as
a famous person like when ask chargpt to
act like Elon Musk and give your
thoughts on AI
so here
we will ask strategiving that is
act as Elon Musk and give your thoughts
on here
so you could see that it has stated that
artificial intelligence was immense
potential for human advancement it's
eventually digital superintelligent and
can go beyond a human intelligence but
it is not saying that it can perfectly
act as Elon Musk or it can directly
speak to Elon Musk where you can provide
a perspective based on his public
statements on the topic of artificial
intelligence so the child CPT has
analyzed all its statements that are
present that is GPT 4 has some browsing
features so it has analyzed all the
statements and on behalf of that it has
given us the result and now moving on to
the next step that is act as an examiner
so you can ask can you check this essay
for grammatical errors you can ask it to
check your project or even grade your
homework so as we have copy pasted the
article you can copy paste your if you
want to check your code or debug your
code you can just give to chat jpt and
it will give you the suggestions or it
will point out some matters and can give
you a perfect code or you can just ask
him to get some grammatical errors in
your article or essay so this was the
10th tip that is act as an examiner and
now the next is format your outputs so
you can give any data to chat jpt and
ask him to format this into tables and
you can ask him to add some columns to
the tables that would be Monday Tuesday
Wednesday and you can ask him to prepare
a to-do list or something like that so
you can format your outputs jjbt will
respond to that
so for that we'll just give it a prompt
to chat apt that is format the days of
week in a table and days put days in
column so let's see so you could see
that it has given us and it has given
all the days in one column so you have
to correct your prompts and rewrite your
prompts and see what chat jpt is
responding with those problems so you
have to be concise and be conscious and
just regenerative problems
now moving on to and next step
that is tip number 12 that is generate
to do list you can say I need to do
grocery shopping finish a report and
call my friend today and can you create
a to-do list for me so chat GPT can
create to-do list just tell it what task
you need to complete and it will create
a to-do list for you you can just you
just have to give it a prompt and the
next tip we have is explain it to a
child so this is you can ask can you
explain how a rocket Works to a
five-year-old you can ask chat Jeopardy
to explain complex Concepts in simple
terms just say explain it to a child
followed by the concept so for example
you can also ask that can you explain
quantum physics to a child so we will
just try this prompt
that is explain
quantum physics
to a child
so this will give you
so you could see that the chat Deputy
has given the answer that is absolutely
there's a very simple way to explain
quantum physics to a child and it has
given a Lego books example you can build
a castle a spaceship or whole city so
this is how you can use this prompt
that was the tip number 13 that is
explaining to his child then the next
step we have is Shadow chat thread links
so after having a productive
conversation with chargeability you can
share this conversation by clicking on
the share button and sending the
generator link to your colleagues this
is a great way to collaborate with
others for instance if you are working
on a project with a team you can share
the link to a chat thread so everyone
can see the conversation and contribute
so I will show you how you can do it
that is this is the share button share a
chat and you can just copy the link and
send it to anyone and you can
collaborate with them and now moving on
to a Next Step that is tip number 15
that is export data to mail if you want
to export a chat you can click on the
export button and enter your email
address you will receive a copy of the
chat in your inbox this shows full
feature is used if you want to save a
record of your conversation or if you
need to share the information with
someone who doesn't have access to
charitivity so I will show you how you
can do it so simply you have to go here
click on settings and go to data
controls and here is your option that is
export data so just click on export
confirm export and the successfully
exported data you should receive an
email shortly with your data and now
moving on we will see another tip that
is
organize your chat history so you can
organize your chat history that is you
can edit it and you can name anything
that is
tips for chat jpd so this is how you can
organize your
chat history
and now moving on
now we'll see the next step that is go
minimalist
so what do you understand where
minimalist is you can just close this
sidebar so this is the minimalist
options here you can just use the chat
GPT here so in settings you can choose a
minimalist theme which will remove any
unnecessary elements from your dashboard
leaving only with Essentials and if you
prefer cleaner look you can go
minimalist and this removes any
unnecessary elements and you can delete
all your history that is in settings you
can find the delete all history button
clicking this will erase all your
previous chats and for privacy reasons
you might want to delete your chat
history you can do this by going to a
settings and selecting delete all
history so this was a tip number 18 that
is delete all your history so we'll just
go to settings
Theta controls and here we have chat
history and training that is turned on
if you will turn off it will just turn
off and it will also act as an incognito
mode and here you can clear all the
chats this will delete all the history
and the next step we have is describe
images and the next is summarize YouTube
videos so this is available with the
beta features of Bing that is you can
just write
describe image
and paste any image link here so the
chat GPT will describe the image for you
and if you want to like know about any
YouTube video so you can just write
describe YouTube video and then paste
the link and it will describe the
YouTube video for you and that is
available with the beta feature of
browsing with Bing and if that is
available with you
and currently that is not available with
me you can like if you if the feature is
available with you that is a beta
feature you would able to see here that
was the beta feature and you can also go
into settings and data and check out if
the feature is available for you or not
now we'll start with that chat jbt to
automate our Excel and we have some
Excel files I will upload them
in the link with the GitHub so you can
freely download them and you can also
try this project with those files and
here we are with the chat jpd so now we
are on the chatgpt website and here you
can see
that they said try chat GPD option and
when we click it we will be redacting to
the chat jpt the chat box and before
that I will show you the home page
it's showing us the samples what we can
do with the chat GPT
the methods
and there's the collect demonstration
data and train a supervised policy like
how it's trained how open AI has trained
the charge gbt and its limitations
they have mentioned all the things here
iterative deployment
and moving on now we'll login
to our chat repeating
I will log in with my Google account
tell us about you and this is my name
and he is asking
my phone number
so I will get this blood so you guys
won't be seeing my phone number okay
he's asking for the code
I'm waiting for the code after entering
the OTP you will be directed to this
page that is chatgpt and this is the
feed box where you can write any query
in the simple natural language that
would be English and the chat GPT would
answer your questions
and if we talk about chat jpt a little
bit information about Judge everybody
that it's an AI powered chatbot that has
been developed by open Ai and the
chatbot understands natural language and
response in a human-like manner it is
based on GPT 3.5 which is a language
model
and the chatbot was unveiled as a
prototype on November 30 2022 while
announcing the chatbot open AI wrote on
its announcement page that we have
trained a model called chat GPT which
interacts in a conversational way the
dialog format makes it possible for chat
GPD to answer follow questions admit its
mistake challenge incorrect premises and
reject inappropriate requests so now we
will talk about the chat jibeti so chat
jbt is an AI powered chat board that has
been developed by the artificial
intelligence and it's been researched by
the company open Ai and the chatbot
understands natural language and
responds in a human-like manner it is
based on GPT 3.5 which is a language
model the chatbot was unveiled as a
prototype on November 30 2022 while
announcing the chatbot open AI wrote on
its announcement page that we have
trained a model called chat GPD which
interacts in a conversational the dialog
format makes it possible for chatgpt to
answer follow-up questions admit its
mistake challenge incorrect premises and
reject inappropriate requests
so this is jgpd and it's been boing all
the developers around the globe
so now we'll start with automating Excel
with the help of chat jbt and with the
help of Python language
first
we will create a folder and see the
Excel files with which
we will use Python and with the help of
chat GPT
we will automate them
so first we'll create a folder for our
project and we will create in Python
projects and name it as
automate Excel using
chatgpt
and inside this
we will open the command prompt
and now we'll open any idea link so that
we will write a request to chat GPT and
he'll answer us with the suitable code
and that code will copy paste into our
idle and run it if it gives any error we
will copy paste the error same to the
chat jpt and as I know he answers them
so here
we will open our ideally and for that we
are writing a command that is code space
period and that will open our ideally
that is Visual Studio mode
now
we have opener ideally and first we'll
create a file here
or first we will see our Excel files on
which we will
do the automation
and for that it will get back to our
folder
and here we have the number folder in
which we have two files that is CSV
files
phone number and phone number two
and other we have the sales folder and
in that we have the date of the sales of
the Year 2022
so we'll use these files
sales and the number
so we'll cut them and
get to a folder
and inside the number file no we'll
start with sales
first we'll do the automation
with the sales files
so we'll open the sales folder
and inside that we will create a file
that would be the py file
and the first automation we would be
doing is concatenating all the files in
a single Excel file we have the files
from January to December that is the
sales files so we will concatenate them
and ask the chat GPT to write the code
sorry to concatenate all these
so for that
we'll name the file as concatenate only
underscore data Dot py
so now
we will give the command to the chat GPT
so here is a child repeating and here
we will write a command for it
that would be I have 12 Excel files
and I want to concatenate them
and we'll also mention the name named
January
is this only
but we'll check with the file January
and then we have February
and moving on
soon we have till December
so we have all these 12 files and now we
will command him
to use python
to concatenate the data inside the 12
axis files into one file
so this is our Command and it's in the
simplest natural language that is the
English language so we'll just press
enter
okay it shows us that an error occurred
if the issue is
so for this thing we will just copy the
open a link and paste it here and open
it
as the chat jpd is seeing a huge traffic
sometimes it shows
these errors
so he's very famous but we are a robot
or not
so
we will agree with the charge ability
and answer its questions here
it's asking again okay now we are clear
with the charge ability and we'll paste
our Command here and press enter
and here you can see that it has started
answering our question that you can use
the pandas library in Python to read in
the data from each of the Excel files
and use the concat function to combine
the data from one levels into one data
frame here's an example of how you want
to use okay
he's going you know very right menu
and he has imported pandas and then
create a data frame and
using the for Loop
is going through all the munch
reading the Excel file
and appending okay done
and result he is concatenating but he
has not created the
Excel file where we can see all the data
and he has also not printed it so what
we want so first we'll see
what does this code do as I have seen so
it will concatenate but it has not
created the Excel file in which we can
see all the data
so we have copied the code
we will paste it here
save it and run it
and most important thing you have to
import the pandas Library
and if you have not installed it please
install it in the command prompt with
the command pip install pandas or you
can use it in the terminal
okay
it has not found
the january.xls
okay so jnu Ary
okay it's spelling we will see
what error it expects
I will save this and run once again
so we'll just copy the error and write
it back to chat GPT and see
how does it respond
okay is seeing is indicating that the
panel server is unable to find the Excel
file you are trying to read it based on
the error message look like the files
are not located in the same directory as
the python script
okay we'll see that but we have
the python script and the library
in the same
folder
yeah
and we'll check once again here
let's put data.py yeah
they are in the same folder and why we
have this error
okay into
so there it is we have opened our
ideally
in
the automated Excel using chat GPD
folder and currently we are in sales
folder
so it is not recognizing
the directory
so what we'll do
we'll copy all these files
copy the sales files
and paste it here
now
now we will run the port that
chat Jeopardy provided us
okay uh yeah it has run successfully
is good successfully okay we'll try once
again and kill the terminal
save it and run it again
now we'll see yeah it has executed
successfully uh but the thing is it has
note
converted it into
a single Excel file for that we will
write
you forgot to
create
the concatenated
file
as we also haven't mentioned in our
Command
specifically
so we have to be specific with our
commands also
let's see
yeah after creating the data frame
to export to a Excel file and we can
just write this command
and index equal to false here okay and
he's giving all the explanations so you
can just read them correct I apologize
for the website to create a new Excel
file that contains a continued data you
can use the to underscore Excel method
of the data frame here is an example of
how you could do this okay you create a
new Excel file name underscore data.xl
SX the same directory as your python
script and it will contain the
concatenated data form
from all of the original Excel file you
could also use a to underscore CSU
method to save the data frame in CSV
format yeah
we can do that also
okay I will
make the xlsx file
and just beneath it
okay uh
yeah
C part two uh
okay
uh we don't need any path we will just
do it here only
here result.2 Excel
data Dot xlsx
so we'll save this and run it
is showing that it has executed
successfully
and yeah outside the seats folder we'll
close it you can see that it has created
the concatenated underscore data.xlsx
so for that we'll move area it has
created it here
will open it
and first I will show you
what these files contain
so every file have the entry of around
thousand
every file has thousand
entries
so the one candidate file should have
around 12 000.
so this is the concentrated underscore
data
and if we go beneath
yeah we can see
.
and it's to the guy it says it has
concatenated all the data
so yeah chat GPT responded and we have
to precise with the commands what we are
writing in English
as it has not mentioned to convert it
into Excel file now when we have written
it again it has done that
now moving on we will do the second
automation
and for that we'll move back to our
ideally and the next automation we would
be doing would be
that we will be
using the sum and the average function
to all the files that is from January to
December files and will
use sum and average function I will show
you we will use
so it's going to get related data
so we'll open the August file
and here
you can see the
quantity in the edge column
so we'll average down the quantity
so what is the average per customer
and
in the J column we have the total cost
so we'll add all the cost in all the
files
this is the August file from January to
December we will do in color match
the average for the quantities and
column J will do the sum of the total
amount per customer
and we'll get it printed at the last
column
that would be we have the Thousand
entries
it's going till
h1001 so we would get it printed on
h1002
and the sum would get it printed on
j1002
okay so moving on we'll close these
files
we will get back to our chat GPD and
give him a command that
I have 12 Excel files
and we will tell him that we have named
them
January
then we have
February
then
we have till December
and now
we want you to use python
to
apply
the sum formula
the sum formula and the average formula
so the sum formula would be applied from
J2 to j1001
let's see okay we have closed file yeah
but I remember
some formula
ROM
J2 to j1001
okay and
the average function
and now we want him to use the average
formula
from H2 to h1001
okay and that would be in all the Excel
files
and we want him to write the results
in the cells and that would be J one
double zero two
and
h1002 is respectively
so we have to be precise with the
commands and we have
an error here that is done and yeah it's
all done
now just
give this command to charge jpt and see
how it answers use dependence library in
Python to renew okay
and perform the sum and average
calculations good and then write the
results back to the same file here is an
example of how you could do this
yeah we are writing in the same file
okay we are importing Finance is PD and
running a loop for all the months
we have red
all the Excel files one by one and
we are taking the cell
um
location okay and doing the sum
and doing the mean
of the H column yeah it's good
accent
yeah
I think it would
do a job
so we'll copy this and create a new file
and name it as
sum Dot py
and inside this we will paste the code
that our GPT has provided us
and we'll run this
and it has executed successfully okay no
uh we got an error that is
okay okay
it has made the mistake
and rooted
okay
let me just see what query
so we wrote I have 12xl files name in
general every two the summary news
python to apply the sum formula from J2
to
j1001 and the average formula from H2 to
h1001 in all the files and write the
results
okay
done
uh we would be a little specific
let's cells j102
and okay
okay okay yeah
I mean once again submit it if we didn't
get
okay yeah now he has used open
or Excel Library that's good
yeah
that would be working first
let's see
what he will provide to us
here
she active and
okay
yeah
I think
oh you can solve the purpose but first
we'll run it
so he is
giving us the explanation for what he
has written this code that is this code
will apply the sum formula to the range
J2 to j1001 and the average formula to
the range H2 to h1001 in all the Excel
files the results will be written in
j1002 and h1002 respectively it is
important to note that this code will
overwrite the original file so that it's
recommended to make a backup okay we
don't need that
and we have backup in the sales folder
also so you can also the read underscore
excellent to underscore Excel function
from pattern
okay
so we'll try this code
uh it is node
return to import OS and guys uh you have
to install all these libraries open py
Excel I have already installed them you
can search on the browser that open py
Excel installation Python and it would
be directed to pypi.com that's the
official website for the particular
libraries and there you can see the
command that will be the PIP install and
the particular command for the module
name
it is showing that it has run
successfully so we'll just see
if it has done its job or not
and in the April file we have in the H
column that is the average of the edge
column that puts the items and in the J
column we have the total sum of the
amount of the customers yeah
the query has run successfully chat GPT
has provided us with the perfect code
hats off to the Jet gbt and moving on
now we'll do some other automations
and now
what we can do
uh
we have other files that is phone number
and phone number two
and what it contains
it contains the phone numbers
so what we could do is
we could add the plus 91 extension that
is the country code for India
we will ask chat repeat to add the
country code plus 91 to both the files
so I'll close these files
and first
we'll cope with them and paste in our
root directory so we don't get any error
and we'll
change the slide
name
instead of iPhone
we will add the underscore
okay
no
we'll move back to charge APD and write
a command
and these files are CSV files node xlsx
file
yeah these are CSV files both the files
are CS files other files are xlsx files
okay so for that we'll write the command
to charge everything that
I have two files
uh
with DOT CSV extension
and they are named
phone underscore
number and the second was named
phone underscore number underscore 2.
okay so we have told the jet GPT that we
have two files and now we will tell him
to use python
to add the country code
and the
country
code
plus nine one
as
string prefix
and that would be adding as a string
prefix else it would only show nine one
it won't show plus so we'll see if chat
GPT understand that or not
as string prefix in both the CSV files
with
column name that was phone
okay now we'll just press enter
and wait for our charge ubt to answer
this query
and we'll see
how it responds
you can use the printers as well okay
and the prefix to the phone numbers and
the modified data packages are okay here
you know
just okay
[Music]
um
it's heading as step string okay it has
an estimate that
and to CSV
run this code will hit in both the files
here I think this will work
we have copied account it's controlled
in both CSV files and the plus timeline
string to the phone numbers and
write the modify data background says
files it's modern to know that this will
or write the original file so it's
required to make a backup with Originals
okay
I could also use the apply function to
add the prefix to the phone number in
the column okay
we can do this also
with the Lambda function
and that's what
this will also do a job
first we'll see this
and we will
create a file
for this Automation and name it as
country code dot py okay
and we'll
paste the code here
and run it for you guys
when showing that it has executed
successfully
uh yeah it has executed successfully
so we'll just
go back to our files
and see
whether the code plus 91 as in prefix or
not okay the numbers
okay the files code only nine one as
the column it's still in the number
format
it hasn't
converted into string format
uh we'll see the second code also
like
yeah it has converted x windows ring
okay Lambda X we'll see
whether it's working or not
it has worked uh and the issue is we
have
change the files permission denied okay
we have opened a file we'll close it
on Save
this and run it again
now it shows it has
executed successfully
we'll open the files
and now if we see
it is showing here now it has added two
nine months
you know
uh so no issues
uh the thing is first we have to
transform it into the string format and
then we can add plus nine one as a
string to that string
so chat Jeopardy misses with the
slightest
implementation the code
now moving on uh we'll see this command
later
if you want to see how we can add plus 9
on I will tell you how to write that
code
okay
so now moving on we will do another
Automation and you would be glad to know
that chat jpt improves the existing code
like uh in the first automation it has
concatenated but it hasn't converted
the concatenated file like it hasn't
created that file it had created the
file when we have returned to it that
you forgot to create that file so chat
jpd it modulates the existing code also
and moving on
now
uh in any
okay we'll open the concatenated
underscore data Dot xlsx
and inside this
okay we have the product line
so what we'll do is
we will change the
name of the electronic assessors to
electronic equipments and home and
lifestyle to Lifestyle
now we'll automate this process
and we can do this automation all the
files also from January to December
so we'll do that only okay
now here
we will command s
okay now we'll command the chat Jeopardy
that using python
I trade
through
all the Excel files
in the
directory so we are asking him to
iterate to all the Excel files in the
directory and we will ask him to replace
electronic assessors
electronic accessories
see the spelling
accessories okay
yeah Electronics SSS with electronic
equipments
and
also ask him
equipments um
[Music]
okay we'll do equipment only
and
home and lifestyle we have chosen yeah
home and lifestyle
and
change it with only
lifestyle
okay so using python we are iterating
through all the Excel files and changing
these
that would be in each Excel file
so we have to be specific without
written language and now we'll save the
modified workbook in
um we'll create another folder and in
that we will save the files
okay
save the
modified
file
in the
out
put folder
and if the folder is not created
we'll ask him to create it
okay
then create one
hold on
and return
okay I don't know why I'm saving this so
I have written that one I will press
enter
so that charge upd can process it and
give us the
code for that
so it's showing us
sweating and that was she was showing us
uh you can use the voice library to
write it to all the Excel files and
actually the panel is laminated to read
in the fence and make the changes and
I'm going to save the modified files
okay here's an example of how you could
do this
now here
we imported OS pandas is PD
and it has written the code we'll copy
that this code will iterate to all the
Excel files in the current actually
replace electronic accessories with
electronic equipment and home and
lifestyle with lifestyle in the data
frame and then save the modified files
in the output folder if the
sorry in the output folder doesn't exist
the script will create it
you would also use replace function to
replace the values in the column okay
this will write it through all the cells
in each row of the Excel sheet and
replace electronic accessories with
electron equipment and home and
lifestyle with lifestyle if the cell
value is equal to the respective string
okay we have copied a code
and now
we will create a file
and
name it as itrade.py
it paste the code here and run it for
you guys
the code has been executed successfully
now we'll see
open all the files not all but yeah let
me open some
that was the previous electronic
resources
okay so it hasn't changed
in this
okay we will open another file
and see if we code the changes in that
or not
that also States the electronic
accessories so it hasn't
done its job
so we'll move back to GPT
and use this code if it functions else
we will write back to the church APD
okay
just a second
okay we are using the replace
and find the next sentence
okay
so for there we have to report the
OS
done
known underscore book
and want that
wait about this
and run it
include these files
okay
now we'll see
if we quote our solution or not
no it's showing electronic accessories
and human lifestyle
so
chat GPT doesn't
go to the code to change them
so we'll ask him another time and with a
different language this time
oops I don't think it has created the
output folder
it has oh sorry
I'm really sorry what I have done is my
mistake
those were the original files
and we have the product line here
and we have electronic accessories here
and that should be equipments
okay uh we have electronic accessories
and lifestyle
let me see my command
okay I have asked them to
change Electronic Services with
electronic equipment and
women lifestyle with live streams so
let's change only lifestyle
and see
okay
uh the E here is small
we'll update that
in the code
you can write this back to charge apt
also but yeah
first
do this
and what am i showing
node has executed successfully
okay
in the output folder we have this number
accessories
that's in the capital E okay okay
so this code is giving us error
we'll see the last code and copy that
and
try to use this
and close the terminal and run it again
it has executed successfully now we will
see the file
and that has changes or not it has not
ask the chat GPD
what have you done brother
using python nitrate through all the
Excel files in the duct and replace
electronic accessories with electronic
equipment and home industrial with
lifestyle okay in each Excel file save
the modified
foreign
ask the same thing once again
to him
and with this electronic accessories oh
sorry
and save the modified file
the output folder and get a folder it
doesn't exist okay
okay
um
[Music]
you can see once again
let's close these files
it's actually rooted successfully now
will open it
and now we can see that it has changed
to electronic equipment
electron equipment
yeah now it has executed successfully
maybe there would be an error
with us while coping it as we have also
created the output folder but we forgot
to see in that photo maybe that could be
the error from our site
now we are done with the
changing of the column names
uh it's the cell names that was
electronic accessories to electron
equipments and home and lifestyle to
Lifestyle
now we'll do the next automation
for that
first we'll open an Excel file
this was in the output folder
you can get back to our main directory
and open the file July
inhale
here we will
filter the Excel file or gender
that is we'll select gender as female
and with the unique values in column
City
and we'll extract the data from
column A to q that would be the whole
data
and for each Unique city value we'll
create a new Excel file for each City
and that will contain data only for that
City and for females only
and after that we'll save this file in a
folder named City so we'll give this
command to chatgpt
and here you can also specify the module
you want chat JP to use for the
particular command
here we will be commanding the chat
Deputy to use the pandas module and for
that we'll write the command
node command in the natural language
we'll give this command to the chat jbd
and for that we'll write using Python
and pandas
filter the
okay we will just pick a single Excel
file or we can
pick the concatenated file
that is concatenated underscore data
filter the
concatenated
underscore data
Dot
Excel SX
Excel file
and that would be or gender
female
and buy the
unique values in column City
we first will give the command
by the
unique values
in the column
City
and after that we want to extract the
data from column A to q that is the
whole sheet
extract the data
from the column
A2
q and for each Unique city value
for each unique
City
value
now we will extract the data
and now we'll create a new Excel file so
for that also we'll give the command to
chat jpd
and we'll write
create a new Excel file
and that would be for each City
okay
so we will write create a new
Excel file
or each City
containing
data
only for
that
City
and four females
okay
and save this file in the
City folder
and if it's
not being there
GPT can create the folder for that also
okay
City folder and
naming the
each file with the city name okay
naming each file
after the
course
bonding
City
okay
now
if the
CT folder that is we have written a
small City
okay
if the city folder doesn't exist
then create it
before seeing the files
okay
now we have given this command to the
chat GPT and it has responded us with
you can use the pandas Library as we
have already mentioned to use that to
read in the contented underscore
data.xlsx file and filter the data for
gender female group the data by the
unique values in the city column and
extract the data from the specified
columns for each group and here is an
example
so we have put the code
we'll wait till chat GPT continues
and we can see that the chat GPT has
completed
and
we will copy this code
proceeding you see return
gender equal to female
City will make the direct preposition
for City Group in female data root Group
by okay City
and you could also use the SN method to
filter the data frame for female gender
okay first
we will see
this
and for
that we will create filter.py
and run the code
it has been executed successfully so now
you'll see that the city folder has been
created or not
I'm not able to see the city folder
okay it's been created
so see okay it's been created
foreign
it's still empty
so we'll give time
okay and we quote an error take
everything
okay okay we will pass this error to
charity first
and after that we'll see what's wrong
with this
on your so that our message you're
saying isn't getting that the column
name is specified in the list
are not present in the data frame it's
likely that the actual column names in
the data frame are different than the
ones you specified in the list
okay let me just see the list
that is concatenated data
go back
and see that is A2
okay it's still r
okay made a little mistake here
so we'll just
change our Command
yeah
this is it
and
instead of Q now we'll write r
and save and submit now we'll see what I
do it
where it would generate for us
I'm going to close this
okay this one will end up in Excel files
we'll turn the data for a few minutes
and group the data by the unique values
in the city column great and extract the
data from the column eight wire for each
Unique city name and then create a new
Excel file for each City containing data
only for that City and four females
files will be saved in the city folder
naming each file after the corresponding
setting okay
it's done now we'll copy this code
and paste it here and see
whether this code works for us or not
so it's been executed successfully
now we have moved to the city okay
it's executing so I will give time
to the code
and it do it so yeah it's been execute
successfully
okay so there were three cities that was
Mandalay
and if I show you the data
you could see
there's the three cities and it has
created the Excel files with the name of
the settings only the unique cities and
it has extracted the data for the gender
female
now we'll see those files
close this
and back
in the city folder
would see them and lay City
and the data is just for the females
so this automation works well with jet
gbt
now moving on we will do one more
automation
and that would be to use Python to
identify what is the count of each
payment mode
so for that
I will just
get you aware of the payment modes in
our sheet and we'll do this automation
on the concatenated data sheet only
so this is the payment column and you
can see the amount of payments that is
evolet cash credit card
and these are repeating so we will use
Python to identify what is the count of
each payment mode from column am
Elementary
and that is from this sheet only and
then we'll create a new sheet and name
it as
count.xlsx and write the count against
each payment method
so we'll give this command to our
chatgpt
and ask him to write the code for our
automation
so we are writing use Python to identify
use Python to identify
what is the
count
of
each
payment method
from
column and the column was n from column
n and that was it
concatenated
underscore data dot xlsx sheet
and
create a new sheet
um
named
count Dot xlsx
and
write the count
against
each payment method
okay
now we have given this command to our
chat jpd and we'll see what it offers to
us you can use the panels okay that's
the same value counts function to get
the count of each main method okay and
you can use the two action method to the
data frame to write the count to a new
sheet okay that's good and he has
imported the pandas library and create
the DF variable in which he has read the
concatenated file and used accounts
function with payment method
and when we go okay the column name is
payment
note payment method I think it would
generate
an error for us
so
this python of each one method from
column
and
and we will specify
column M and that is named
payment
as it has used payment method here you
can see
that it has used the
column name as payment method
so we'll specify this
we have to be very specific with our
commands
for these automations for simple tasks
you can use
simple language
no complex sentences or you have to
mention every detail but for these
automations you have to use them
now our chat Deputy is working with this
and mostly he will deliver us with the
perfect code I hope so
okay uh
it has red and the value count and it
has
exported
what he said
okay
okay we'll see this
and here
we will
create a file
s count Dot py
and in this file we'll paste the code
delivered us by the chatgpt
we have
executed it
it's being executed we'll wait for that
its main execute successfully
so we have back to our folder
and we have to look for
well count file now yeah account file
okay
it is okay yeah it's showing us the
mode of payment status evolit cash
credit card and the number of
usage
you know four four eight thousand three
yeah it's 12000 that was the whole entry
of the account candidated underscore
data Dot xlsx so we have done with this
Automation and now we will do one last
automation
and first we'll
close all these files
okay
and moving back towards GPT and now we
will do
we will rename all the 12 Excel files
that was January February to December
and we will add the word
car sales
just before the month name that would we
will just add the prefix before the
month name
and for that
we will give the command to the chat GPT
in the natural language and here only
we'll change it
in the mid director only as we have the
copy of all these files
so for this we'll write the command use
python
to rename
all the 12 Excel files
named
January
February
until December
okay
and that is present in my directory
and what we have to do is we have to
add
the word
will add Car Sales okay
car sales
and
in front of
each
each file name
okay
so what it will do is Car Sales
underscore January Car Sales underscore
February and so on
so we'll wait for the chat GPD you can
use the OS library to iterate through
all the Excel files and indictment then
use the restore training function okay
to rename the files here is an example
of how you could do this
go to S and we have the months
okay
this code will iterate through all the
Excel files in the current directory and
add car sales in front of each file name
and those files would be those only the
months
and good it's using the glow module
and you could also use the global model
okay that's the second chord
it's the easy one okay
but we'll go with OS first
and get back to R
Aid ideally and name the file as rename
Dot py
and here we'll paste the code
and run it
it's been executed
will move back yeah you could see that
car sales have been added to all the
files
and with that we have done with our
automations
and if you want you can also submit your
code to chatgpt and ask it to add
commands to your code so that it could
explain you what that line does or what
that function does it would explain very
tediously and
if you want you can also try chat gbd to
automate many office tasks
you can automate PowerPoint for that and
do many more tasks with chat jpd on that
note we present you postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning elevate your
professional journey by enrolling in
this Ai and ml course presented through
a partnership between Purdue University
and IBM hurry up and enroll Now find the
complete course details from the link
mentioned in the description box below
during our childhood we have heard the
fictional stories of robots taking over
various household courses making the
lives of humans easy peasy but if you
are not aware then these fictional
stories are turning into reality though
not in the form of physical robots but
yes in the form of computer programs and
apps with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
Technologies
confused let me introduce to you to chat
GPT a pre-trained model that interacts
with user in a conversational way Chad
GPD is founded by open Ai and the model
is based on supervised and reinforcement
learning so are you excited to know more
about chat GPT chat GPT has various
application in various domains in this
video we are going to see the
application of chat gbt in the SEO
domain also we are going to discuss how
chat GPT will play an important role in
search engine optimization so here is a
question for you chat GPT is based on
which of the following GPT models
created by openai Option 1 chat gpt1
option 2 chat gbd2 option 3 chat GPT 3
and option for none of the above let us
know your answer in the comment section
below and if your answer is correct you
will get a heart from Simply La so to
begin with let's open chat GPT
we need to go to new chat which is
already open here
let's start by we will try to
demonstrate an SEO optimized blog in
this demonstration so let's get some
keyword ideas for the blog
so before that let's choose what kind of
blog we want to create I really love
traveling so let's try to create a
travel blog so for the travel blog we'll
find some good keywords
yeah
foreign
so here you can see we are getting some
suggestions for the travel destinations
we can choose any of them
okay so here we got around seven of the
results
so let's try to get something for Japan
so just me with keywords to create a
blog
born with Japan
okay so what I understand from this is
we are just getting few of the random
keywords
Okay so
it is
it is showing that these keywords cover
a range of topics related to Japanese
culture history food and more
uh out of these I guess
we can start
with the places here are few places like
Mount Fiji
Tokyo and everything so let's try to
create a blog
on top 10 places to visit in Japan
okay so we are getting places to visit
in Japan
foreign
let's try to get keywords related to top
10 places in Japan
okay so we are getting some of the
keyword recommendations
and it is also suggesting that by using
these keywords our content will be more
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank for search for for search rankings
write me a Blog on
top 10
places
to visit
in
Japan
so the idea is we will try to write a
blog and after which we will try to
optimize the block with respect to the
keyword top 10 places to visit in Japan
and we will also see whether all the SEO
practices can be easily applicable or
not using chat GPT
so here you can see we are getting a
Blog with the introduction with top 10
places and probably what I expect is to
get a good conclusion out of it
also like uh uh a chat jpt provides you
the facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the blog or article or anything
you want to say every number of words
like if this Blog has two thousand or
five thousand words you can just ask
chat GPT to reduce it to two thousand or
thousand words also
so here you can see that
before when we searched there were only
one liners about these destinations
these places in Japan and now we are
getting a detail about all the 10 places
definitely we have targeted this block
for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more keywords
to increase its reach
suggest
you
more development
keywords for my blog
okay so we are getting some more
keywords here
for any blog it is really important to
have a very good title so we will try to
implement a catchy title for this blog
foreign
as a good title helps the user to click
on your
content and it increases the possibility
to get more and more traffic
so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimize our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which are somewhat similar
to what we are expecting
add the best
suitable
title
in my blog
okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's hidden gems 10 places you can't
miss
okay so here we got title for a Blog but
here we can see there is a slight
limitation that it is suggesting the
title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my blog
for the keyword
top 10
places to
visit in Japan top 10 places to visit in
Japan
but then
optimized
title
okay so we have to do it manually it's
not able to
add the title on the Block
optimize
blog
for the
keyword
top 10 places to visit and
okay so here it is showing their
relevant suggestions
so maybe there is a slight
ambiguity in the query that's why it's
not representing us the correct results
we are going to optimize our blog using
all these factors
foreign
again these are the suggestions
let's try to implement these one by one
foreign
s H1 H2
in the above block
so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and H2
and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in H2
H1 and S2 tags are some of the practices
in the on-page optimization which helps
the search engine boards to understand
that this is something important really
important for the page and they pick up
these hints for getting your page rank
so yes it is implemented
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2 implementations
let's try to get some interlinks for
this blog interlinks have their own
importance as interlinking your blog
with other pages of your website or your
blogging Pages this will help you to
gain the traffic from other pages to
your blog and putting the traffic from
your blog to other pages of your website
also it helps the search engine boards
to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure also
so
suggest me few
intern links
for the above block
so yes definitely these are the relevant
and expected links we are getting so if
you have any of these blog pages in your
website or if you have created any of
these blogs earlier do Interlink it
which of the above
can I use in my blog so definitely there
are number of suggestions but if you
want to choose one how can you pick the
one let's see if we get the relevant
thing for this
okay
so it is not only suggesting that we can
use all of the above
but it is also showing the significance
of interlinking
okay moving ahead
so till now we have optimized our blog
for a keyword top 10 places we have
tried to get some of the keywords
relevant to the top 10 places to visit
in Japan we have added headings and we
have tried to get some of the good
Interlink suggestions to add interlinks
in our blogs which are some of the good
practices of the on page optimizations
so next moving ahead in another on-page
optimization technique is let's try to
get a cover image for this blog
so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
blog page
okay so it is showing uh some of the
suggestions related to
the diversity of the country the normic
view of Tokyo Skyline the beautiful
image of kuyoto's traditional Temple
Mount Fuji hiroshima's peace Memorial
Park
so we will try to pick one and uh see if
we are getting any image idea
let's take for Mount Fuji
suggest me the image
idea for Mount
so let's see we have seen in generic for
all now let's see for this uh image
suggestion specific to Mount Fuji
okay definitely it is showing a number
of suggestions for the specific Mount
Fuji image
so if you are looking to create another
block for Mount Fuji then these ideas
are easy to take up
optimize
the mount
Fuji image for my blog
here are some tips to optimize the image
for Mount Fuji for my blog which are
they're showing that the image should be
high resolution
then a clear subject
definitely if you have a large image a
large file size it really gets difficult
to load and the page load speed will
increase so if you have a large file
size the image should be compressed
without reducing its quality image
quality
we should have descriptive file names
and all tags
okay
so let's try to get a very good file
name and ALT tag also we'll try to
implement a good caption because adding
a caption is very good in the when
considered as a user
so
get me
title and
all right
tag
for
you
image
so there is importance for ltac as
search engines are the Bots they won't
able to identify the image directly so
all tags helps the search engines to
understand what the image is about
so yes it is showing not one but number
of suggestions for all the Mount Fuji
recommendations which we got earlier
so we will try to choose one and get a
caption for it
right a good
caption
for
for the image
scenic
fusy
Lakes Region
so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions here
I guess this caption is quite long so
let's try to reduce it to
40 words
reduce the above
caption
to
not even 40 let's do it in 20 20 words
okay this one is better
now let's try to get the image if there
is any
shoes
the amount
you'll see image for my blog
choose image
it should not I repeat
choose the perfect
illustration for
Mount Fuji
image for my
blog
so you can see here that it is not
choosing any image but it is again
providing us a suggestion what we can
choose
again this is the limitation that it is
not showing us any of the image we will
try to put it in another way to get an
image
if it really works we can get it
okay so it is not possible to download
or get an image representation using
chat GPT
we can only get the recommendations to
choose the image and yes it is showing
some suggestions of UNS and unsplash
pixels or Shutterstock to download the
image so we can really navigate to these
websites and download some of the
required image
for our blog
so we we have uh completed here with the
image optimizations let's try to get
some video ideas because again having a
video is a catchy factor for the users
visiting your website
for your blog page
suggest me
suggest
do ideas
about
block
okay so we are getting few of the video
ideas
which of the
other idea is best match for my blog
let's try to extract anyone from the
above
okay so it is completely dependent on
the user's Choice what a user wants so
here I'll choose
for
again we will continue with Mount Fuji
only
provide with your optimization
optimization ideas
video optimizations
for
Mount
fusy video
for above block
okay so it is showing us some of the
suggestions what we uh which we can
Implement for a video as we do not have
any video here we can just take these
recommendations and optimize whatever
the video of our choice
so let's take the thumbnail suggestions
in our next query if it can suggest us a
mount fusey uh thumbnail uh image
suggestion and the video tag suggestion
right
just me
good
thumbnail idea
for Mount Fuji
video
thumbnails have the Major Impact for any
videos it is the only thing
um
I repeat
thumbnails
thumbnails are one of the important
factors which encourages the user to
click on your video and watch the
complete video
so definitely having a good thumbnail
will help your content to rank
so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh as of the video we
are having for our blog
so we are done with the thumbnail ideas
after which we will get
we will try to get video tags so for
getting video tags let's get for all of
them
find me
video
tags
all of above
thumbnail
suggestions
times are important to help the user to
get your videos in the search list
like if someone uh uh types Mount Fuji
in the search box and if the Mount Fuji
keyword is or a tag is added to your
video tag it is more likely to get
searched and appear in the search
results and possibly use a May click on
it
so here we have tried to get uh try to
implement some of the good uh some of
the important
on-page optimization practices now let's
try to get backlinks which is one of the
most famous of page optimization
technique
above block
okay so it is showing
some of the link suggestions
so basically backlinks are the links
which points from other another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website
so getting backlink is one of the trust
factors in the search engine size that
your content is really unique and more
of more users wants to read it and share
it with another users
so the search engines by by these search
engines understand that your content is
really good and it is worth of ranking
so definitely getting a good backlink
from a very good authority websites is
fruitful for your content
so let's try to get
pages
on web are
suitable
to get
backlinks for my blog
so here we are getting some of the ideas
or suggestions that which Pages we can
choose to get a backlink
so here is industry specific websites so
if you are writing a travel blog there
should be a travel trip advice a Trip
Advisor like websites
which are showing more of the trip
oriented or bookings related oriented
for travel or destinations
there are few of the directories
okay government websites which are the
tourism websites in our case right now
blogging websites and social media
platforms
which can be relevant to the current
scenario which we are using here
so
let's check
how can we get
backlinks
from the
above
recommendations
for my blog
okay guest posting
broken link building
okay these are some of the backlink
building methods which we are getting
so that we can find one and get one of
the black button
a repeat
so these are some of the battling
building strategies which we are getting
in the recommendation so we can
Implement any of these to get a batting
for our blog
let's choose the specific platform
and try to get the recommendations
or the ideas to get backlinks for the
from the blogging site
so we can Implement these ideas and it
it may be possible to get backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks whatever blog let's try
to add the catchy metadata for our blog
metadata like having meta title or meta
description these are the only data
which is which is appearing in the
search results as you you have seen that
in the search result the link the Blue
Link we get is the meta title of our
blog page or a website page or any page
on the web whereas a few lines written
below that link is the meta description
that we are providing to
let the user know that what the blog is
exactly about so it is considered to be
a good practice to have the targeted
keyword in the title as well as in the
description so let's try to get one
is the
create SEO
optimize
meta title and meta
description for my blog
so we are getting some suggestions here
top 10 places to visit in Japan discover
the best place to visit in Japan top 10
destinations definitely we have here top
10 destinations
see also we are getting some of the
notes that
it is good to have meta title less than
60 characters
so if if it is more than 60 character
you may get the dot dot part and the
title will not be clearly visible in the
search result page
so let's try to again optimize The Meta
title and meta description for top 10
places to visit in Japan
description
keyword
stop them
places to
visit in Japan
okay
so we can use any of the one the one we
have got the recommendation the
previously and this one also both are
completely relevant to our content
so one of the technical SEO factor which
we are going to see here is getting the
URL recommendation uh URLs are the
important factor uh it helps the search
engine boards to understand about the
page as the URL is the first thing
search engines may be visiting to come
to your page
so
uh it is a good practice to have the
keyword in your url rather than having
some of the abrupt characters like x a r
at the rate these kind of stuffs in the
link
so let's create
the URL suggestions
suggest me
SEO optimized
URL for the
above block
see so here
we are getting top 10 places to visit in
Japan which is definitely our blog and
as a keyword we are using it to optimize
our content and it is placed in the URL
so this URL is completely correct
also these kind of suggestions are very
good for the newbies in the search
engine domain as they will definitely
understand why and what we are doing to
optimize our pages
so next
moving ahead with some of the
non-technical aspects which may impact
which may definitely impact to bring the
traffic so let's try to get some of the
sharing suggestions like
bits
platforms
should I
repeat
which
sharing options
should I add in my blog
so out of the mentioned sharing buttons
we can add any of them
adding at least three to four sharing
buttons is considered to be really good
out of which there are many common like
Facebook is really common then Reddit is
really very common watchup shells are
really common Twitter Shares are really
common
so you can choose any of these to add it
in your blogs
thus commenting
on
my blog
impact
on
traffic source so here we are taking the
suggestion that will this help or not
again this is again linked to the
backlinks that if we are adding the
comment section someone else may ask for
backing for their web and this is again
going in symbiotic way like if they are
asking for a battling for from your blog
you can even ask from them
so this is the way of or a part of a
communication to get a backlinks as well
can you find the
duplicate
content
content above block so duplicate content
is a concept where search engines you
you must be aware that search engines
are really in love with the unique
content so having a duplicate content
may really
affect your web visibility and it is
possible that your page may get dead
after a Time
so plagiarism is not at all allowed uh
when you're creating a content
it is not suggested in any case
okay so it is not able to charge if it
is not able to identify the duplicate
content however it is suggesting us some
of the tools like copyscape or siteliner
to understand if the content we are
creating for our blog is duplicate or
not
and let's get some suggestions how to
make
content
unique
just in case if someone is not aware to
create unique content
we can get some of the tips here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical SEO
that is four not four pages four not
four pages are
really
not are not likely to get searched
because
I repeat
let's try to see another aspect of
technical SEO
uh try to find some four not four pages
on the website
foreign
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
that blog which we are expecting this is
not the clear idea we are providing but
yes uh to find four not four pages
uh it is not possible for the sharp GPT
to get one but we can use some of the
tools suggested like uh screaming frog
or Google search console where we get
the detailed report of the broken links
or 404 pages that is the dead pages of a
website
so let's wrap up from the view of the
technical SEO perspective
please consider one of the scenario that
we have published this blog and how can
we promote this blog to reach more of
the relevant audience
so
okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer add it as a guest post
and Link back to this
this blog email marketing yes it is the
most trending technique to reach more of
the audiences
paid advertising commenting
content syndication
yes medium and Linkedin are the very
famous platforms for this
online communities
so you can you can definitely try to be
the member of the online communities and
forums where you can just put up the
link and the members of your Niche may
definitely visit your
a content and share it with others also
so yes we we have seen that uh search
for as as a perspective of search engine
optimization chat GPT is uh helpful
really really helpful to create the in
content Creation in optimizations and
many of the other things
today in an era of mobile devices robots
and social media content creation is the
most effective inbound marketing
strategy
nearly 40 percent of marketers say
content marketing is essential to their
marketing strategy and 81 percent say
their company views content as a
business strategy
original and high quality content can
help your company stand out and attract
your customers and help your business
grow on that note welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel today we are here
with a fantastic video on chat GPT for
Content creation which will help you
create some compelling content on your
desired topics so let us understand what
is chat GPT here now content creation
can be of any type such as blogs
podcasts videos graphics and so on but
how do you create high quality content
with a few minutes you not be worried
when we have chat GPT now even though
there are numerous AI writing tools for
Content creation chat GPT stands for the
crowd due to its faster response rate
ease of use increased productivity
support for multiple languages and other
benefits now let's try to understand
what exactly chat Jupiter is and how to
create content from it
now generally chat GPT is an open AI
trained and developed model that works
conversationally
chat GPT is capable of systematically
resolving all bugs while providing
detailed explanation for each step it
takes so in simple words chat GPT is a
tool that creates content for any query
chart GPT stands out among all the other
achievements of open AI
so let us now move ahead and understand
how does chat GPT work now chat GPT uses
deep learning techniques to generate
human-like text which is based on a
machine learning model derived from the
large language model class now it is
trained on a massive Text data sets from
the internet and learns patterns and
relationship between words and phrases
it responds to a question by selecting
the next word based on the context and
then repeats the process until a stop
condition is fulfilled so as a result
chart GPT can logically respond to your
queries and commands so let's see how to
create content in chat GPT now as we
already discussed content creation can
be of any type so for instance let's
take blog a Blog is an online general or
a website where a writer or a group of
writers share their views on an
individual subject now there are a
variety of categories for writing a Blog
so let's pick one for chart GPD here
so as you can see we have navigated into
chat GPT and let us now ask a simple
question about food blocking now lately
food blogs are the most popular blogs
that everyone wants to write about so
let's find out what chat GPT has to say
about it now you can give any question
to charge GPT and it will answer so I'm
just writing a question here saying how
to
start a foot
vlogging carrier
so as you can see it is generating the
answer for us wait for it to end
well as you can see it is saying that
starting a foot block can be a fun and
rewarding way to share your love of food
with others so it is showing us some
steps to get started in food blogging
career it is saying choose Anisha choose
a name and domain choose a blogging
platform create your blog create high
quality content and so on so in this way
charging people automatically generate
the response for you based on the
questions that you are giving input to
it next we will see another question on
lifestyle blogs now with the world on
social media everyone wants to read more
about lifestyle especially of a famous
or a popular entity what habits they
adapt and what to let go of Etc so let's
explore this segment in chat GPT as well
and see what it will show the answer so
let's give the question as how to
start
lifestyle
blogging in India
so it is giving the answer for us guys
so it is saying that starting a
lifestyle blog in India can be a great
way to share your experiences and
knowledge with others who share similar
interest so here are some steps to help
you get started again it is giving some
uh important points whereas in order to
start your lifestyle blogging career
like choose your Niche choose a name and
domain choosing a blogging platform
create your blog create high quality
content and so on jet GPT is truly a
fascinating technology changing how we
interact with language it's the result
of years of research and development by
open AI who have trained the model on a
massive amount of Text data to create a
machine that can easily understand and
generate human-like text imagine you are
a digital marketer looking to make a big
impact on your next campaign chair GPT
can help you do that charge gbt uses
natural language processing or NLP which
can assist you in creating compelling
human-like copy for your website social
media and email marketing it can even
generate product descriptions and AD
copy that is engaging and optimized for
search engines using chatgpt will save
time and increase your productivity
allowing you to focus on other important
aspects of your campaign and with its
ability to generate multiple text
variations you can test and Define your
messaging to find the perfect tone and
language that resonates with your target
audience get ready to revolutionize your
digital marketing game with the help of
this video you will gain a deeper
understanding of how 10 GPT can
supercharge your efforts as a content
creator or digital marketer say goodbye
to mundane tasks and hello to a 10-fold
boost in productivity let's dive in ever
since open AI launched chatgpt it has
been making waves in every feed be it
academic marketing engineering or
content writing so here's a little
trivia for you who are the investors in
open AI the company behind the
development of CI jpd and your
[Music]
drop your answer in the comment section
Below on that note we present you
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning elevate your professional
journey by enrolling in this Ai and ml
course presented through a partnership
between Purdue University and IBM hurry
up and enroll Now find the complete
course details from the link mentioned
in the description box below okay then
let's get started there are many uses of
charge GPT in digital marketing its main
USB is smart human sounding content
writing we can command it to write
content related to marketing first on
our agenda is an ad copy there are
various ways to go about it but we must
understand that no matter how much
content sounds like humans it is still a
piece of content written by an AI so you
have to give detailed and size queries
to get the best results let's start by
giving it a basic command like write an
ad copy
as you can see it gave us random ad
content let's give this query more
content like write an ad copy for simply
learned digital marketing Master's
course
[Music]
now as you can see it gave us a more
precise ad copy we can also ask to make
it longer or shorter let's give it a
next query can you make it longer
[Music]
and vola it gave us a long version of
that same content now let's try to
convert it into email newsletters V
digital marketers often send emails to
promote our products and services so
let's give it a query as can you convert
it to email newsletters
thank you
as you can see it has generated an email
with a subject line and body that is
enticing and engaging to read we can
also utilize chat GPT to correct grammar
or change the tone of the content for
example let's enter new query what is
Facebook
foreign
[Music]
of Facebook now let's ask it to rephrase
it more engagingly and in a digital
marketing context we can give queries
like can you make it more engaging and
relatable with digital marketing
[Music]
as you can see it has completely
replaced it and it is more interesting
to read it as well chatgpt can also help
with keyword research so let's try it we
will give a query as suggest more such
keywords for a digital marketing course
site
[Music]
thank you
and vola it has completed a work we used
to spend 10 to 15 minutes in a few
seconds you can request to write blogs
as well let's give it a query to search
for some keywords for the blog suggest
keywords to write a blog on digital
marketing
foreign
it gave us some keywords you can ask it
to reduce these topics based on search
volume to get maximum results let's ask
it to narrow it down to five topics
based on keywords volume
[Music]
here we have some suggestions let's pick
a topic content writing and ask it to
write an article on content writing
[Music]
here we have our article for the blog
let's use chatgpt to as you optimize it
let's first request it to give us meta
title and meta description
[Music]
here we have meta title and meta
description for this article we can even
request it to give us an SEO optimized
URL link
we can also request it to write the SC
optimized version of this article just
give it a command as also can you as you
optimize this article to improve Google
search results
[Music]
foreign
optimized article with meta title and
meta description where the SEO optimized
URL chat GPD can also be used to train
your customer service chat boards but we
can discuss the process in some other
video chatgpt is well burst with its
content writing capabilities it can even
help you write product marketing
campaigns let's try it with this query
the queries write a product marketing
campaign Force Implement digital
marketing courses
thank you
well chat jbt has done it again this
campaign looks interesting and it will
be able to generate more leads for
simple lens courses chat jbt can also be
used to write scripts for YouTube videos
let's give it a query as write a script
for five minute YouTube video promoting
simply learn and its digital marketing
courses
foreign
[Music]
as you can see it gave us full script
along with few suggestions for video
editor on where to put logos and clips
to make the video more engaging if you
are a content creator and you don't know
how to approach other content creators
for a collaborative video then chatgpt
can help you with that it can help you
writing collaboration emails as well my
next query will be to write a
collaborative email for a YouTube video
on digital marketing
[Music]
thank you
since my last query was related to
Simply none chat Deputy assured that I
work for simplion and I wrote a customer
collaboration email that looks
professional plus easy to read and
understand let me tell you what chart
GPT is chargpt is a machine model that
generates human-like text responses it's
been generated on a massive data set of
text and can generate highly accurate
responses to a wide range of queries
but how can charge GPT be used for web
development
there are number of ways for example
charge jabetic can generate website
content improving SEO and boosting
engagement
chat GPT can also be used to create chat
boards that can interact with customers
in a natural and engaging way now let's
look at some of the real live examples
of how charge GPT has been used for web
development so for example if I ask rgbd
to create a e-commerce website for me it
will easily create it so let's see it
please create
a website
for me
in HTML
and CSS
so there is one point that I wanted to
tell you guys if you want to ask chargpt
for anything just give good description
about it so it can give you a good
response if I tell you tell it more
about my requirements it will generate
good quality of product okay
so let me delete please create a website
for me in CSS and HTML
that should
some
like orange
and blue
right
and
where I'm selling
okay now lay wait for the response of
charge EBT it will create us
the things the code okay now it's
writing the HTML code right
so I'll tell you more about it like for
example e-commerce sites use charge gbt
to generate product descriptions
improving their SEO and driving sales
customer service team use LGBT to create
automated chat boards that can help
customers with common queries and there
are so many other things also like
content creators also use charity to
generate engaging content for their
website right so let's wait a couple of
minutes more until it gets completed
right so as you can see it's giving us a
proper response of everything
as it created this file for us
and we can just easily copy it from here
and I have logged into my online editor
you can open any editor if you want
so this is the online editor that I'm
working on right now I'll clean this
so as you can see
e-commerce website is ready right
so this is a very basic website but
charge EBT has created this for us
it's very easy website like very basic
but as the instructions that I gave it
it applied all the things that it's
using yellow color but I asked for
orange but it's fine uh blue color so
this is also fine but before asking
chart gbt you should know a little bit
about coding right so in H1 tag here
you have to write the heading is the
header tag inside that it's the H1 The
Heading one
okay
so here I'll write my website name
I'll write website
and then you can see the joint
website right
so how can you use adjpt for your own
web development projects first you have
to familiar yourself with the
programming languages and tools that are
compatible with chargeability and it
will only knows the data until 2021
so once you have done that you can
experience with charge gbt to see how it
can benefit your project
right if I ask him to create wait I'll
show you guys some of the things that
rgbt can do
create a header
so I have told rgbt to create a header
and make it functional and also add
page product page and contact this page
make it a little more I have written
make it attractive right so let's see
it will write us a code for that so
until then let me tell you the use cases
so as I already mentioned chat GPT has
already proven its value in various web
development scenarios
for example e-commerce platform use
charge APD to generate product
descriptions boosting their search
engine optimization and driving more
sales
customer service team employee charge
GPT to build interactive chat boards
that provides instant and accurate
responses to customer queries enhancing
the overall user experience
so optimize the generated content from
SEO ensures that the text generated by
charge gbt aligns with relevant keywords
and follow SEO best practices right so
with the help of charge GPT SEO things
this can help improve your website
visibility in search engine results and
it can create natural and authentic
chatbot experience so when using charge
GPT to develop chat boards focus on
creating conversation that feels like
human
use context and personalization to
ensure user engagement and build trust
leverage our GPT for customer engagement
Beyond generating content right charge
apt can help engage user on your website
also for instance you can use it to
develop interactivity and so many other
things okay so now let's see
what rgbt has created for us right let's
copy this
and paste it on the online editor that I
have showed you
I don't recommend using online editor
you can have a visual studio code it's
very good
so it doesn't have any CSS I guess yeah
add your customer custom styles for
product pages here yeah so as I know you
have to write the CSS here but it's fine
I have to show you something different
so as I told it to create the e-commerce
website so it give a given its name as
welcome to e-commerce website but we can
change it from here the title of the
website we can change it right
and I have told it to create home
product and
contact page right as I have showed you
so it has created the same thing that I
have told charging video to create for
me as in the products page there's known
things added right now but we can add it
add your products and their details here
as it's written in the code also I guess
yeah in this section part we can add our
product and the things that we want
right now let's ask chargity to create
Circle
create five
server different
radius
or 20 pixels
to
your pixel right and
[Music]
and
plus blue and
Orange
now let's see whether it can create five
circles of different radius for us or
not
right and now it's writing the HTML file
for us
let's wait a couple of seconds to see
whether it can create so it given us the
things we want but I don't think so it
has
different
radius okay as you can see in the CSS
part it is given everything a different
height and width let's copy the CSS
first or HTML anything you want and
we'll paste it on the online editor
let's go again and copy the HTML part
also and
paste it here now
we will
down and as you can see the first circle
is small and then the last one is the
largest one right so as you I have given
it the charge GPT the instructions that
I want this thing or that thing it has
created the same thing that I told him
to to right so it's all about
instructions but as I know that this is
width and height this is very simple
thing but when you'll code on python or
JavaScript or Java it'll be a very
complex things so I recommend first
learn the language and then use charge
ability to improve it right so many
developers in programmers use
charitability to enhance their
productivity
not to learn it so it's very good for
learning purpose also if I tell it
I want to learn
Javas I say
Java
from
where
should
start
start learning it
give me
some
princess
and
some
good
sides
from where
I can start
with the
Links of them
right so I asked charity to tell me from
where should I start learning the HD
Java so it's now telling that's great
Java is a popular programming language
as there are many resources available to
help you learn it here are some of the
website and resources where you can
start learning Java right
so it's giving me Oracle Java tutorials
it's very good to learn Java from Java
programming on core serum it's giving
some of the renowned Java certification
courses but I recommend you to take our
Java certification full stack Java
certification the link will be in the
description box for that it's a very
good certification for newly starting
developer or programmer or experience
one also so from there you will start
learning Java from scratch so that is
also very good
you can also check it out right so as I
told it to give me the instructions from
how to learn Java so it just gave me
everything with the links right
so now
let's get to
give me any
projects ideas
for
react
yes
right
so now it's telling me
you can create a project on react for
from starting from to-do list which is a
very basic app when you start learning
any language you started by from to-do
list only or doodoo app whatever you say
next one is weather app movie Library
which is also very good practice for
Library uh for react developers to start
learning reaction and the e-commerce
store it's a Founder chat application
and these are the 10 projects that they
the charge ability told us to learn
right so it's very good you can ask it
anything if you don't know anything
like I'll tell you
react JS right
I don't know think
about react yes
please
about it
so I told it I don't know anything about
the ideas I know about the IGS but it's
like I want to see what it's saying you
can also check out the projects that I
have created on react on this simply
learns YouTube channel so uh that's
saying everything certainly react.js is
a popular JavaScript library for
building user interfaces it was
developed by Facebook and it is widely
used for building single page
application it's a dynamic application
so some of the key points of react
component based architecture virtual Dom
and declarative syntax unidirectional
data flow react Hooks and so many other
things so as you don't know in anything
about react it will tell you to get
started with react you can begin by
learning fundamentals of JavaScript and
familiarize yourself with HTML and CSS
once you have a good understanding of
these Technologies you can explore
react.js by following tutorials reading
documentation I recommend documentation
because it's very good you will get a
deep understanding of that then move to
tutorials and all and build small
projects it is also very good thing
start from learning from the projects
you will learn more react official
document is here so Excel resource to
learn react yes from scratch
additionally there are various online
courses tutorials and YouTube channels
dedicated to teaching learning reactors
such as reactors on these platforms and
you can and also learn react from our
YouTube channel remember to to practice
regularly build projects to refine
yours learning and leverage the react.js
community for support and guidance
as technology advances in all aspects of
Our Lives programming has become
increasingly important it is used in
many fields and industries including
software development gaming and
entertainment education scientific
research web development and many more
so needless to say the demand for
programming and coding in the IT
industry will probably keep increasing
for the foreseeable future but where
does charge Deputy open ai's popular
language model fall in this chain that's
exactly what you're focusing on in this
today's video as I said earlier
programming is utilized in many domains
like web development robotics mobile
development machine learning and so on
so how can a program achieve maximum
code efficiency nowadays we have EI
based tools like chargeability to make
our programming experience more
efficient although there are several
coding resources platforms such as stack
Overflow and GitHub where programmers
can find solutions to their technical
programming questions charging stands
out from the competition because of its
quick response time time usability and
support for numerous languages among
many other benefits now let's first
discuss how tagipity Works chat
generates responses to the text input
using a method called Transformer
architecture a large volume of text is
fed into the charge GPT from various
sources including books websites and
other social media platforms the model
then uses this information to forecast
the following word in a phrase based on
the words that came before it the charge
ability systems allows users to enter
text or queries and then the system uses
its training data and algorithms to
produce the right answer the answer is
created after the input text has been
examined and the pattern most likely to
match the input have been identified
using the training data in short charge
APD is designed to respond to queries
logically and command more quickly and
accurately but why do programmers use
strategypt on a regular basis charge
Deputy assist programmers by offering
programming related answers and
solutions and helping them improve their
skills besides that charge Deputy is
utilized for code generation code
completion code review and a natural
language interface let us understand
each in detail chat day is trained to
generate the code or even the entire
program described in the natural
language specified by what they want a
program to do and then charging could
generate the relevant code look at the
example of how chargpt generates the
code so now open the charge GPT and you
can type any program that you want rgbt
to generate so I will give write a
parlington program in Java so here you
can type write a
palindrome
program in Java
so using Java programming language it
should generate the whole program
so as you can see it has generated the
program so it has used a class name
called palindrome Checker and it has
used ease palindrome as a method name
and also it will give the explanation on
the program so you can see here why it
is explaining why each palindrome is
used as a method and it also explains
the for Loop if
a condition and so on next we have code
completion charging is trained to
generate Snippets of code or even fully
fledged programs it can generate a list
of possible code completion depending on
the context of the user's incomplete
piece of Code by automatically producing
the entire code it can help the
developers save time and minimize errors
next let's see the example of code
completion using tatibility so even if
the program is explained in natural
language chargpt will generate the
proper code and give the complete code
so let's type here
using a function
write a program
to convert
this string
in uppercase
so using which language let's keep using
C programming
and enter it once again
so as you can see we have just said that
using a function write a program to
convert the string in uppercase so using
C programming language and using C
programming language it has used
function and you know this is the
function convert to uppercase and has
come given the complete code for string
to convert a string in uppercase and
also it gave the explanation here the
convert to uppercase function takes a
pointer to a string as its argument and
then iterates over each character in the
string using a for Loop so it explained
why for Loop is used why two upper is
used and why the method convert to
uppercase is used everything
so let's say we'll give one piece of
code like void
to Upper
care
Str
so as you can see we just gave the
method to Upper and it's generating the
complete code
so this is how chargpt works for code
completion next code review charging can
analyze code identify the box or errors
in the program and further help resolve
them it allows developers to fix errors
more quickly so now let's have a look at
the example of code review so in this
example chat Deputy will review the code
so even if the code has some mistake it
will give the proper output let's say we
have given the example here
so we gave
the function or a method called upper
and here we are giving
the keyword called upward so you should
check whether this piece of code is
proper or is there any mistake in this
so as I said
uh it's saying that the given code
appears to have logical error as a
function upper is being called
recursively on itself inside the loop
so instead of giving two upper we just
gave upper here right so using the
keyword to Upper only then this string
can be converted to uppercase so here we
gave just upper so it says that it is
having this piece of code is having a
logical error and it gives a proper code
for us
so I hope it's clear
and then we have natural language
interface with the use of chargept a
software application can be given a
natural language user interface that
enables users to communicate with it
through natural language instructions
rather than through conventional user
interfaces next let's see how tragedy
helps the programmers for natural
language interface so let's say we'll
give here
create
a software application
where
the user
asked to enter
credential
for the to-do app
inventor
so as you can see
the charge video will give the steps so
it can provide you with an outlet for
creating a software applications that
requires the user to enter credential
for a to-do app
so here it is few steps that we need to
follow to do a to-do app
so it's giving the explanation step by
step
so it says that determine the
programming language and framework then
set up the database to store the user
information and then create the
registration page and then finally
create the login page as well and once
the user is successfully logged in
um you know it will have the options
like add edit and delete task as well
and then finally implement the security
measures to you know protect your
passwords and then test the application
to ensure that it works as intended and
the user data is being stored and
retrieved correctly so it gives the
steps of how it has to be developed
I'm sure you all are aware of charging
at this point the Revolutionary new AI
based chatbot developed by open AI have
taken the World by storm thanks to its
near lifelike responses and a very
intricate pattern of answers they have
never seen this level of expertise from
a chatbot before which really made us
think to what extent can we push it
there are many questions on lead code
that even the most experienced
programmers have difficulty answering so
we wanted to see how far charge GPD can
take us hobby finally reached the stage
where AI is going to replace us let's
find out so basically here we will be
listing 10 really difficult questions
that we found on lead code popularly
asked while hiring and other Superior
examinations and see if charge GPD can
actually answer or solve those difficult
questions or not but before you like to
watch more such interesting videos then
do subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn so let's get
started so here is the lead code let's
see uh in our list which is the first
question that we are going to implement
in our chat GPD and see if it's able to
solve it or not
mainly we'll focus on hard category
questions only so
according to my research there's a
question of median
of two sorted arrays
so as you can see the success rate is
35.7 so let's see the chart GPT is able
to do this question so first let us go
through the question
okay
press enter let's see what it first
returns
uh on a one approach to solving this
problem is to use the modified binary
search algorithm to find the median of
the two sorted arrays so right now it's
particularly giving the logic which we
can actually imply to solve this
question
and uh this is a good but the charge GPD
is that before uh giving the code it's
actually explaining how they had putting
the logic in together in the code
so probably you can use this logic to
create your own program but let's see
how sensible this code is
quite a learning program
is in Python so if you are looking for
your Solutions on chat GPD you can
always opt out or you know mention the
specific program you want the code in
so okay it's it's also gives that okay
that the time complexity will be o log
Min m or n so let's see if it
the case or not
so we have copied it
and we quickly paste it over here
as you can see
uh as we know that python is uh very
sensitive towards its uh
syntax and you can see the indentation
over here is perfect but here it's not
so I feel that something like this is
something with lead code
so let me just quickly Rectify this you
can see I have cleared out the
indentation issue and let's just quickly
run this program so that we can get an
idea if this is the correct program
uh now you can see here we have an error
let's see copy this and see what charge
GPD has to say for this
so if you remember when we actually saw
this question there were three arguments
passed through this function which was
self nums 1 and nums two ask GPT if it
can write the code with self-argument
and see if it's correct
and wait that if it can pass a
self-argument through that function and
see if it can generate a new code
okay now it has cleared that yes it
takes three arguments
let's
copy this code
put it over here again I think we will
have to go through the indentation
process
oh no this time it's fine okay so now
quickly run this program let's see if
this time it passes all the test cases
or not
I think it doesn't need because the
class is already mentioned over here
uh
yeah
okay the runtime is 35 Ms and as you can
see case 1 and case two is definitely
passed
so
let us see if
this code can pass all the test cases
internally mentioned in this question
now you can see the first three cases
are actually accepted but the other
three are not there's a runtime error
so
the first question in our list chat GPT
was unable to solve let's move on to our
next question
others zigzag conversion
now let me quickly search for it
this is a question here also you can see
the success rate is definitely below 50
and the difficulty level is medium so
the Hard One charging body was not able
to solve let's see if this can be done
so it will give a string that will be
written in a zigzag pattern on a given
number of rows
and then you have to read the line in a
certain
as you can see over here
we have to write the code that will take
a string and make this conversion given
in a number of row
has also means a certain amount of
certificate uh repeat that's also given
a certain specifications that we exactly
want so this time we'll make sure that
we are mentioning everything
so let's quickly copy this
okay
okay now that we have mentioned all the
specifications
uh let me quickly
feed
feed based let's see what code it has to
generate
it's implementing the code in C plus
plus so meanwhile it's generating the
code let's quickly
like the code oh it's already C plus
plus okay
okay it's also suggesting that we can
definitely use Python and Java
and it's generating an alternative code
as well for us
that's Sharp
oh
just quickly copy this code
[Music]
one I think it's a okay so it's
generating in uh
Java
let's generating we'll definitely have a
look at its alternative codes as well
let's quickly have a look at what it has
to C plus plus one the first code
generated by it
uh is correct or not
okay copy the code
paste it over here
dilation Arrow
okay okay
28 okay
so let's quickly this error
the one thing
definitely this time we have mentioned
all the constraints criteria
specifications that we wanted in a code
but again
judge
what questions we have implemented till
now
let's see if it has any success rate in
further
okay it seems okay
now it is okay so this time it is uh
generating the solution
considering the error in Java
uh see what it has to say in Java and
we'll make it specific that the error
was in C plus plus program so generates
the correct code
plus plus program
what it has to say
oh this thing is
let's see so this error is something
related to the compiler and now it is
giving the updated code in C plus plus
is the correct one or not
apologizing for making errors in their
Solutions
quite fascinating
[Music]
um
paste the code over here I don't see
there's a lot of difference or changes
over here let's see if it runs or not
let me see if the all the braces are
covered over here or not
I think it's missing a brace
okay
okay so there was a syntax error one
brace was missing
um I don't
for that
definitely something with the code but
okay we can give that to charge GPT it
was
partially lead quotes issue because we
were copying still it was not giving the
error that there is a brace missing
has passed the first three cases
mentioned over here and the run time is
3M is now just let us submit this code
and see if it passes all the rest of the
cases or not mind it this time we have
actually mentioned all the constraints
so let's see if this has two into
okay so this time it has passed all the
test cases but still my conclusion with
this question is uh it was still not
able to generate the solution in one go
uh but so I can give that to charge GPT
because the first error that we faced
was more of a lead code is issue
because it was something with company
and charge gbt was able to give a proper
oh now let's go back to our problems
list
so
right now the score is one and one it
was unable to solve one question and one
not
so let's have a look at the third
question and see if that brings any
difference to the chart gpts
scoreboard right now or not
third question that we are going to deal
with is substring
with
concatenation of all words
this is in the category again and the
success success rate is 31.1 percent
which is even lesser than the first
question that we faced which was median
of the two sorted Aries
here we are actually trying to cover all
the Spectra the huge Spectra of
different types of
questions and you know categories
available in coding and to give you an
idea of how
beneficial charging can be for you to
solve difficult questions which can be
helpful for your interview base in
companies or you can say well
established companies among companies so
here this video is specifically for you
to give an idea that whether you can use
it for your benefit and you know to get
an idea or you can actually
compare it with
your
subjects uh and you can get a you know
wider range of different types of
approaches to a certain question
so let's start with the third question
is that you're given a string and an
array of strings probably words and all
the strings or words are of the same
length now a concatenated substring in s
is a substring that contains all the
strings of any permutation of words
concatenated
here you can see it's given an example
that if words has a b c d e f then a b c
d e f basically uh has done all the
permutation and combinations that can be
done using that
there's a big added
uh
e c d b e f is not a concatenated
substring because it is not the
concatenation of any permeation of words
so we have to basically return the
starting indices of all the concatenated
substring in the S string
also you can choose any order for it
here it has also given a
two examples for you to
understand the question in a better
perspective
now
really a copy this question and see if
what programming language algebra
chooses to answer this time
but with no chat again
be these constraints
okay it's just a question
okay
this is the solution that you are
getting right now you requested a model
that is not compatible with this engine
please contact us through our health
center at health
dot openai.com for further questions let
me just quickly refresh it if it has a
something to do with the you know demand
also sometimes it happens that the
console is very busy and you're unable
to implement
uh your task in it so again let's
quickly
paste it over here
that we want a code write the code
return now
press enter
same definitely it's not giving the same
error
let's see it this time it charger PD has
anything to give as a solution
okay so it's generating the code in
Python
the more thing every time chargeability
doesn't follows a similar pattern as you
can see in the first question it
explained the logic first and then
implemented the code second time it just
gave you the approach not the logic and
then implemented the code in multiple
languages uh first choosing for C plus
plus
and this time it's straight away wind
for the code so definitely we can say
that it has some different styles of
generating their code and explaining the
code I think it depends on the
understanding how they want the code to
be presented in front of the user and to
give the perspective that if the code is
understandable or not and if the code
has multiple approaches I think charge
if it is capable to capable enough to
give that
that the code is generated let's quickly
copy it
and
paste it over here
I feel the indentation issue is going to
be there
but it was not there okay
F probably I think if we backspeed
issue let me quickly Rectify this and
I'll
show you once the indentations are
but
the indentation is projected now let's
have a look
at the Gold if it's correct or not let's
quickly run it
definitely it has a given our first
syntax error again
I can see that even specific video
question it definitely goes to at least
one error which is mainly the syntax one
sure if that is something with the lead
code or you know with the
charge GPT code generation
okay
all right we have given the error okay
it seems that the error is caused by the
use of type hints the function type in
so introduced in the version we are
using is lower than that okay so
basically it's generating now in the
python version
uh probably this code is
well suited for different version of
python let's change it then
and see if that helps
knit
is actually generating the code
okay again
given the other one I think it's again
something with the self
uh
I didn't want the new code generated is
here
will definitely come back to that error
and have a look at the Python 3 code
also
uh first let's copy this code
and
in giving the same error
and see what it has to say
uh you know every time the charge APD
generates the python code we cannot
ever takes self as an argument but
believe that
as you can see when we start the code
it's already mentioned what arguments we
need to pass from
a particular function so I think that is
something with the lead code so
that what all arguments it's passing
even though we have mentioned everything
this time we have mentioned all the
constraints we have mentioned all the
necessary
specifications that we want in the code
even then the code is not correct in the
one goal so probably I'll get this point
to GPT it's something with the lead code
because it's passing that parameter and
everything we have to mention that
parameter pretty much when we do the
chargeability is able to solve the
question so let's see let me actually
mention that
because self parameter self argument
from that parameters I'm gonna make it
one of the parameters
processing that
yes self can be passed as the first
argument to the given function now let's
see if that it's able to give the
correct solution or not again we can see
it's uh generating the code and you know
Python 3
but we can give that to charge GPD that
either it uses python or Python 3 the
error is with the self argument
so once we mentioned that error and when
we mention that specification that if
charging between pass self argument
through that particular function in that
code the solution is pretty much
right so here it's also implementing and
giving the answer
okay it also has mentioned that it's
important to mention import important
list and counter so okay
just copy this because again there will
be a lot of uh inpatient issues
okay now that we have it
copy the code
I was already mentioned so yeah we'll
just
copy it from the function
paste it
let's run this code and see if it has
the solution in it or not
yeah there is an indentation issue
let me
again as you can see it is able to pass
all the test cases here and the run time
is 28 MMS
now let us submit this question and see
if it is able to pass other test cases
or not
accepted
so it is able to pass all the test cases
and I think this is something with lead
code again uh whenever we are generating
the python code we are actually passing
self argument uh in lead code but charge
GPD is not assuming it so this solution
is definitely correct
even though we are specifying everything
we will have to be more specific that we
have to run one more argument uh from
the function so that it you know
generates the solution in one go so let
us try that in our next question
we can definitely see charge APD was
able to solve this so now the scoreboard
is two and one one uh among three
questions it is definitely able to solve
two questions even the first question it
was able to generate a correct solution
but it was not that accurate to pass all
the test cases
to a question list
the next question that we are going to
cover is in Queens
category but still the success rate is
63 over here again a new genre or
question we are covering over here let
us see it
solve it or not definitely the success
rate shows that many people were able to
do it definitely more than half of
people who have attempted it so see if
the question can
this AI can beat that or not
so I have to copy this question this
question mentions that the end Queens
puzzle is the problem of placing n
Queens on an N into N Chess board such
that no two queens attack each other
given an integer n written all distinct
solutions to the end Queen puzzle
so basically n is any given number and
you have to create a puzzle of end in
and you have to arrange all the Queens
in such uh you know way also the number
of Queens in the board will be equal to
the number
in and in such a way that it is not able
to attack each other in any case
puppet this part of the question
and the constraint is
just one let me
that it will be easy to keep a track of
what all questions charging is able to
solve
so these questions are very popular uh
in interviews uh whenever you actually
go to technical rounds and for
prestigious companies these questions
are very popular uh they are considered
as very uh suitable questions to check
to check your you know IQ and to check
your potential that how well aware you
are towards your coding potential
now we have pressed enter it is giving
the logic it is going to implement in
its code one approach to solve the end
Queens puzzle is to use backtracking
I guess to start by placing a queen in
the First Column of the first row so
let's see if the course
again capable to you know
solve it or not
again it's giving the python code
generating the code let us quickly see
whether it's python or Python 3
written python 3.
okay
once the code is generated I'll also
write that you need to pass one more
argument from the main function
uh that is self and let let it generate
the code again and see that code can run
in one go or not
should what I want and delete this C
sure here's an example of how you can
pass an additional parameter self let's
see if it suits
the code or not
from the 12 and queen function is a
method of the end Queens class and it
takes self as its first parameter
followed by the integer n so yes this
solution does take self as a parameter
so let's see if this can
run in one go or not because this time
we have already covered the most uh
frequently generated error which is
syntax error of not mentioning parameter
self
actually
let me see the indentation if it's
correct or not
this time uh let us quickly run this
class
okay there you go now you can see that
it has actually run the code in one go
and all the test cases are passed in one
go even the runtime is 39 Ms so
definitely charge gbt is able to provide
the solutions the Logics in a proper
manner it's just that we have to be more
specific with what we want exactly uh
from chat GPT right now we can see that
it has been able to successfully
generate 4 out of five uh questions that
we have actually implemented till now
out of which four are from hard category
let us submit this code and see if it
also covers all the test cases
internally fed in for this question just
a second I think I will have to submit
it again
thank you cool it has accepted all the
test cases and this question is done by
child GPT it has actually implemented
this question that we are going to cover
till now I can say charge gbd has taken
the lead it is pretty much able to
implement all the questions uh I think
there are still some range of questions
that it is not able to implement as we
saw the first one was not a huge success
but um I can still give that to charge
upd as it is in Ai and still in a you
know developing mode but still if it can
give you 90 of the output correct it is
a pretty decent and you know amazing
thing to do
question is shortest sabare with some at
least K now let me search
for it
again this question is from hard
category and its success rate is even
low which is 26.1 let's see if this
question can be solved by chart GPT
let's have a look at the question given
an integer ad in nums and an integer K
return the length of the shortest non
empty sub array of nums with a sum of at
least K so if there is no such sub array
return minus 1.
so
the body is a contagious part of an
array it has also given a description of
what an array is or what sub array is
so now that we have
a new chat
and let me
explains
so here is one way to solve the problem
initialize two pointers uh left and
right both pointing to the first element
of the array initialize a variable so
now this time this it is giving pointers
to solve this question uh you know a
perfect approach in a sequential manner
so that you can also use these pointers
and the Logics it's giving to actually
Implement your own code apart from you
know asking it to generate a code
I can see that it has given the pointers
but not the code
specific
so yes it's giving an implementation of
the algorithm in Python
uh again we can see it's not the Python
3 it's python uh little lower version of
python
um
50.
let's do
python
then we have to pass self
so it has generated code and explain
what all variables and what will
statements have the individual
functionality as so we have also asked
it to pass self parameter through its
function and then write the code so
let's see if it adheres to it and
generates new code with self parameter
okay so here
is the new code with self parameter
passed through the main function
now I do have confidence on chat GPT
till now that it was able to generate
logical and you know
pretty much decent solutions for every
question
the spouse to the class as an argument
when an object is created and is stored
as an instance variable the shortest sub
array takes K as an argument which is
the target sum so basically it's trying
to explain the code that what exactly
it's doing and what individual
statements have as an influence on the
code
and whatever parameters they are passing
what influence or what position they
hold in the code
so definitely charge APD is not just
generating the code uh you know it's
also explaining the logic and approaches
towards it
and when it's generating the code as you
can see here they have legit explain the
whole code how it's actually functioning
that's a good way to you know put
emphasis on you know put a confidence on
the solution
remove this
I better okay
okay so it's apologizing it made a
mistake in its previous response the
init method should take two arguments
one for the nums array and one for key
so now it's again generating a new code
or adhering to the syntax error or type
error generated
right or not
mentioned that here direct method takes
two arguments one for the nums array and
one for the K which was the error
exactly
and it's again explaining the whole code
so that one person who watches code or
you know logic could understand the
functionality of it
let's say this code can run
food
checking for indentation removing class
and run
it's one more type error
let's copy it and
and we mentioned that we want
self-argument to be passed
it is still not able to generate
you know the correct solution twice
so let's see this time it can work out
issue though with the code
apologize for the confusion seems that I
misunderstood
that you are trying to call the function
directly without creating an instance of
the class and that
function outside of the class and simply
Call It by passing the parameters like
this okay the code is definitely
generated by itself so definitely I am
not calling any function uh the code I
copied was actually generated by
charging itself so it's contradicting
its own pointers Maybe
right we have copied the question uh
sorry the code
let's paste it
again look for indentation
and run this code
okay once again it is not able to you
know
us
I am error is there and now again we
have to copy this error and paste it
again according to chat GPD it was
confused with the context of the
question
uh like I said the code was anyway
generated by Char GPT so yeah
this time I think GPT is trying to
contradict its own logics
let's see if the current code can do the
miracle of solving this question
last
and run
okay so after four attempts of running
the codes generated by charge GPD on
delete code but this particular question
finally now it's able to pass all the
test cases so
I can I have a very contradicting point
right now uh
not exactly contradicting more of a
skepticism that okay Chad Jeopardy does
generate a proper code or logic but it
doesn't considers all the criterias or
it also has a tendency of taking the
question in a wrong context
so I feel that when we as a human try to
solve these questions we definitely try
to implement all the Logics and if we
get it we can actually get the code in
one go
or you know demand of the question
and be AI being Superior version or you
know trying to be the superior version
of human brain and going to the extents
of a human brain
still faces those issues
can be uh you know drawback for chat GPT
because you can see for this specific
question we have face multiple types of
error and we have seen charge Equity
contradicting its own prior code
so
definitely this is something to consider
or you know something to think about
submit this code
you can have like I said after giving
four attempts it is still not able to
pass all the test cases it is only able
to six pass 61 out of 97 test cases
which is almost 70 percent of the test
cases 30k percent of this test cases are
still not passed even though we
mentioned all the constraints we have
mentioned the comments we have mentioned
all the errors that but this particular
code can go through
still it was not able to generate the
proper code that could go through all
the test cases
so
this was a fail for chart GPT uh at
least till now we have made out this
point that charge GPT is definitely not
able to solve every question
array with same average
for it
lit
array with
this is from the category of hard
questions and the success read is only
25 percent
Let me refresh it and remove this code
now let's have a look at the code what
it demands so you are given an integer
Harry nums now you should move each
element of nums into one of two arrays e
and B so can B are non-empty and the
average of array a is equal to average
of array B now return true if it is
possible to achieve that
condition is not justified
so given a note that for an array uh
average re is the sum of all the
elements of array over the length of
array okay so it is giving the lodge of
how to actually you know find out the
average of what average is exactly
and also it is given a few examples to
give you how the code needs to be
projected or implemented
please copy the code and paste it
okay it is possible to achieve this by
checking all the possible subsets of the
nums array and comparing the averages of
the subsets so definitely it has given
you the approach uh the way you can
actually think of solving this question
however this approach would have a Time
complexity so it's also giving that this
approach can have a Time complexity of O
to the power n so again it's suggesting
a different approach a more efficient
approach that will be using dynamic
programming now that can be used to find
the subsets with a specific average and
create a 2d array with the length of I
and J which that will be the length of
the two
we have actually given as input and
represents whether or not it is possible
to get a sum of J using the first
means of the nums array
so
[Music]
so the time complexity of this approach
would be o and S so definitely it is not
given a code let me ask for it
not for every question chart GPD is
generating a code it is also mentioning
just and the approaches that we can
actually use uh definitely again we will
have to mention that what we want from
them
as you can see I've mentioned this time
to write a code for it and now it's
generating a new code for it
also mentioning comments that what every
snippet of the code is actually for and
what it will do like here you can see it
will fill the 2D r2dp uh DP stands for
dynamic programming this here it has
mentioned initialized the First Column
as true so it is also mentioning the
comments for better idea of you know
understanding the code in a better way
it's also giving the note that this
implementation assumes that the nums are
is non-empty and that the elements of
the nums array are non-negative integers
okay also the above implementation will
return the possible subset that can be
formed by the array to fulfill the given
condition and not Boolean true and false
but that's what we want exactly right
uh still okay let this
this approach is in Python so let's copy
this and
see this code can run or not
I can clearly see that again it needs to
pass self
uh
parameter
indentation
and
foreign
specifically
uh
sure here is an example of how you can
pass the cell parameter so now the
current solution will pass self
okay
great there was an error okay
and it has generated a new code uh
considering the
criteria I just mentioned that I need
self parameter to be passed through the
function can partnership
so I have copied it and let's quickly
paste it over here
uh you know pass
all the cases are not wait uh we need to
remove this
okay it's done now quickly just run this
program
okay so here is uh
error attribute error solution object
has no attribute okay so let me copy it
and paste it over here and see what Char
GPT has to say about this error
okay the error message solution object
has no attribute
uh split array same average suggests
that there is no method named with this
in the solution class so it is likely
that the test case is trying to call
this method but it does not exist in
your implementation anyway that I have
not mentioned this method this was given
by charging itself so again we can see
the condition that it is contradicting
its own so again it has generated new
response and it says that it should
resolve the issue and the test case
should be able to call this particular
method correctly
so that is something for us to decide
now let us copy this code and see that
now is it able to run or not and pass
all these test cases or not
and click on run
okay now the new generated response it
does works for this particular question
and the runtime is 12 Ms and it
trespasses the first two cases mentioned
so let us quickly submit this code and
see if the code is perfectly you know
fine to deal with all the test cases
actually fed by lead code
okay now again we can see one more
situation that this code is not able to
pass all the test cases even though we
mentioned all the specifications
constraints and we were pretty precise
about the questions and parameters that
we want our code to be done in certain
form but still it is just able to pass
68 test cases out of 111 which is almost
50 to 60 percent of uh total amount of
test cases
so let's move on to the next question
that is find substring with given hash
value so let me quickly search for this
question
find substring
with
which value again it's
it's a question from hard category and
the success rate is
22.2 percent so let's have a look at the
question what it demands so here the
hash of a zero indexed string of length
K given integers B and M is computed
using the following functions now hash
with parameters SPM
uh this is the logic given how we want
our output to be demonstrated in certain
value or how the hash can be generated
the particular formula uh how you can
get the hash value of your you know
string
so the question is you are given a
string and then teachers
and you have to return the first
substring of that string of length uh
given to you here it's K the test cases
will be generated such that and answer
always exists we are going to copy this
course and mention all the
specifications mentioned here in their
charging console so that it gets
all the specifications
with the code and
so I have copied the code and I'll paste
it over here now let's check for
indentation it's fine let's remove class
my class
and
with Janet faces a type error so let's
move on to the next question again we
saw that charging was not able to solve
this particular question coming back to
our list the next question in the list
that we are going to cover is partition
array into two arrays to minimize some
difference let's quickly search for that
question
I want to shouldn't add a
to
two arrays
again this question is from hard
category and the success rate is even
more low so let's have a look at the
question first it's partition array into
two arrays to minimize some difference
that is generated as the output
or we can see that there are three
constraints so now quickly we'll copy
this question and see if it is able to
solve this question or not first we have
to create a new chat
I'll be
all the constraints
let's see what charge ability has to say
for this particular question
let's
ask it to generate a code this time it
has only generated a logic not exactly
Logic the approach indeed they are going
to follow or anyone can follow to solve
this question
let me ask if it can generate a code
okay it's definitely taking longer time
to generate this code
okay here is the code which is possible
python implementation and
[Music]
okay the code is generated and it's
mentioning that the code takes in an
input an array of integer called nums so
basically uh it's explaining that what
it actually is doing which is pretty
much explained in the question itself
that what exactly it needs to function
like and what will be the variables and
what will be the inputs and how it needs
to be segregated to uh obtain our
Optimum result
so
let's copy this
and
paste it over here again like I said we
can see that it's generating you know uh
again we could see that
past self parameter
okay
attribute error let's quickly copy it
paste it over here
see what chart GPT has to say about it
okay
that you have seen that after placing
the error it's giving that error message
you're seeing suggests that there's a
problem with the function name in your
code so the error message is indicating
that there is no function called minimum
difference within the solution uh also I
have seen that apart from the function
name it doesn't have a self parameter so
let me just write it down
well
argument
it
apps let me copy it that will be better
and write the
new code with it
let me see if it can generate a new code
this time
so yeah it has a great show there is an
example and here's the code
I have copied this
and
paste it over
here any such huge difference in the
syntax or the logic of the code
but yeah we can definitely think of
running now
let's run this code
we copy it and paste it over here again
an error has prompted out I
don't know how valid
code will get after projecting this
error over here in charge GPD
so yeah definitely considering the error
message you are seeing is indicated that
the function is returning INF which is
not a valid value for the expected
return type integer
so in the base case where I and J are
both 0 the value of is set to float
which is positively Infinity however the
expected output is an integer so this
valid this value is not valid so again
considering this change the
chargeability is giving a new code so
let us see how valid this new code is
okay I can see that it has changed the
logic over here instead of float INF it
has changed but it has uh written a new
syntax and your logic over there
let's see how accurate charge GPT here
is
now okay we have pasted logic
uh yeah as
oh sorry I need to remove these two
lines
now let's quickly run this program
okay so now as you can see it could only
pass one test case
but not the first two so there's no
point of submitting this code as we can
see that the logic for the score or this
code and as a whole is not
well moving on
next in the list we have is
longest common subpar now let's see
longest
common
subpath
so this question also comes from
category of hard questions and the
success rate is 27 now let's see what
this question demands actually now let's
quickly copy this question with all the
constraints and whatever apart from
example is left on the screen we need to
copy it as you can see over here you can
not just miss out on any specifications
talking about the constraints copy
and paste
now enter
giving the approach to solve this
question which is dynamic programming
approach okay we didn't want any code
over here so let's try
that if it can present a code
because I have asked to write a code for
this and yes charge GPT has definitely
agreed to provide me a code for it uh
charging is done with its explanations
I'll type it out and wait for the new
code which will contain self as a
parameter that it's the score is pretty
similar to the previous one it's just
that it's using the self argument in the
function as it was mentioned by me
so let's quickly copy this code
paste it over here
check for the indentation
we run this code
okay I spoke too fast here we have
another error let's see what charge EBD
has to say about this
okay the list index out of range error
is likely occurring on line 10 because
the indices I and J are being properly
bounds checked before being used to
access elements in the path and TP
arrays okay so we have found a new code
let's quickly copy this code and see if
this code is capable of you know
eliminating the errors we
probably found
click copy and paste
let me check correlation
done and run
then we got a error over here even
though after providing so many
specifications and criterias and errors
and conditions yet charge GPU is not
able to provide a perfect solution for
the code
uh moving on to the last question of our
list
that is going to be uh sum of total
strength of wizards hopefully this
question does from marry for child GPT
and prove itself lucky which rgbt graph
for this video because for now we can
see it's a 50 50 scene uh half of the
question chargible was able to provide
Solutions with and half other questions
charging Beauty couldn't actually figure
out what
needs to be done even the logic and
approach was correct still the
implementation of the code was not
correct
so let me search for this
question some of total
strength of wizards again a hard
category question
so let's have a look at the question
first
let's click copy this question
create a new chat
paste it over here
and
look for constraints now that we have
copied it
paste it and enter
he is giving an approach how you can
actually think of a solution for this
particular question charge ability has
not generated any code uh let me ask for
it
okay
so here's an example again they have
implemented the code in Python now it is
also giving a note that the approach is
valid only if you are allowed to modify
the original array and also we are not
working on down over
function and then write this
code so let's see if we can do it with
self argument
okay so yeah there's an example it's
generating the code
okay so let's see
what's the update with the code
here
this
episode are
let's add
solution
and run the code
so there's a runtime error let me see
why
okay
this error
and paste it over here
your charger body have to say
the error message solution object has no
attribute mod suggest that there is a
class name solution and the code is
trying to access an attribute named mod
on an instance of that class with
attribute doesn't exist we probably need
to make more specifications and if it
still doesn't works then it clearly
classifies that charge GPD doesn't takes
every point or a classification uh you
know in consideration uh which
ultimately uh
you know reflects on the solution
the new code is here let me quickly
paste it
okay
by running this code let's see if this
works
try running it again
again it has a runtime error was unable
to solve one more question now that we
have tried and tested a huge spectrum of
questions from Lead Core on charge GPT
we can conclude that though charge GPD
is an amazing tool with the bright
future it still has its own limitations
and maybe it is not ready to replace
humans or compete with human brains
these questions were picked from a list
of frequently asked questions for
interviews and examinations chat GPT
does have a potential to generate Logics
and approaches for the code in an
effective manner but still its ability
to analyze the question is weak as
compared to humans as we know these
questions are there the success rate
just shows that a proper solution do
exist for these questions but still even
after multiple attempts charge GPD was
not able to find the correct answer but
we can also give charging the benefit of
doubt that it's still it's in its
initial phase and still there are a lot
of aspects that need to be worked on so
probably in future charge GPT can take
an upper hand over this but for now
needs to do a lot of work for these
situations on that note we present you
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning elevate your professional
journey by enrolling in this Ai and ml
course presented through a partnership
between Purdue University and IBM hurry
up and enroll Now find the complete
course details from the link mentioned
in the description box below we'll start
with our project
and for that first we'll create a folder
in Python projects
and name it as
Telegram
Port using chat jbd
okay and inside this we'll open the
current prompt and open our
ID that is I would be using the video
Studio code and you can use any ID that
you have Hands-On
and now
we will go back to our chat GPT
and we'll start here but before that
let's talk about telegram board so a
telegram Port is a program that
interacts with users via the telegram
messaging app
uh the pretty Quizlet is you should have
a telegram account and Boards can be
used for a wide range of purposes such
as customer support news delivery and
even games
and chat Jeopardy so chat Jeopardy is a
large language model trained by open AI
that is based on gbd 3.5 architecture
and charitivity is capable of generating
human-like response through text based
inputs making it a great tool for
building chat boards
and now if we talk about prerequisites
you should have a telegram account
python installed on your system and we
need a python telegram board library
that I will show you what to install and
that charge APD will tell us equal to
install
so we'll just ask chat deputy
to create
telegram board
using
python
okay so it says error we'll just refresh
the page
ask again create telegram board
using python okay
I will see what
instance so Creator telegram board you
need a telegram
mode token to the board father yeah we
have to go to the word folder I will
show you guys how to do that
install the required libraries next you
need to install
okay and write this code
okay
so in this script
they have started with the start
function so
it will just says hello
when it will be started
okay
so we'll add some more functionalities
and
we will ask where to find the
your API token here so I know like we
have to go to the
World further but we will ask charity
video also
we can we find
the
repeat open
so it states that to get to telegram
about API token you need to create a new
word by talking to the board further on
Telegram
open telegram and search for board
father okay and send the board further
message that is Slash new mode and the
board father will ask you for the name
of the board and
it will ask you about the username and
if it is the word father will then
generate a token for your board this
token is a string of characters that
uniquely identifies your board on
Telegram so keep this token secure and I
will also blur it so you guys won't be
able to see it okay
so moving to a telegram
we will just search
board further here
and you can see this is the board father
and we'll just click on start
and they asked the chat GPT asked us to
write Slash new word we'll just click on
this and we'll get
so we'll write a new mode how are we
going to call it please choose our name
for the board
so right
simply learn
underscore new
import okay
good let's choose an username
so simply
and learn
one one underscore port
and it states that that your username
should end in both
so we have landed with board
and you could see the token here and
here you can just access your board
so
we'll get back to our ID and create a
new file and I will name it as new DOT
py only
or you can name it as board.viewer
anything you want
we'll get back to our
charge GPD but before that first we need
to install the library
for that you can go to the command
prompt or you could use the terminal of
your ID
that is
in Visual Studio code you could you
could use the terminal to install the
libraries you could see that the
requirement is already satisfied
as this
library is already installed on the
system
so moving back library is installed and
now we'll copy this code
and paste it here
and we will just change the token
we will go back to board further
we'll copy this token
come back
and paste it here
okay
now we will
run this and see whether our border is
working or not
so it has successfully executed
I will get back to our board father and
just
click on simply 111 board
so
we click on start
and see it says hello I'm your board so
it's working fine
so if we write hello
it won't respond as there are no
functionality so we will ask chat deputy
to add functionalities
and
some more
functionality piece
and this modes
to the port
let's see
so sure here's an example of how you can
add some more reality
so they used what up data in this
picture okay
let me find the help command Handler
okay
so
chat GPT has defined three functions
that is Eco and what does equal to it
will just give you the same thing but
you give to the board or what you write
to the board caps that
he has also declared a help function and
in which you can see like what
functionalities does the board have and
the Caps will do it will convert the
message to all caps Eco Echo the message
back to you it will give you the same
message
slash start it will start the board and
slash help to get help
and now
unknown uh if there is something you ask
out of these things it will just say
sorry
okay
I will
let you guys understand this code also
but first we'll see whether it's working
or not
with that we have pasted it here
and we'll paste our API token again
so I pasted it here now first we will
close this terminal and
get a new terminal and then run the
program
I will get back to the
mode further and this is our port
so we'll just write slash
start
and it says hello I am your board
now
we'll say
hi to the bot
okay it's not responding
okay we'll just close the terminal and
we have pasted the
Keys also okay
done it again
now we'll see whether it's working or
not
hi
so the code is not working
and just see the hole again
okay uh
here we don't have
any response to eye or yellow
so what we'll do
we'll use the help and to call the help
but we have slash help
so these are the commands for what it
will respond
so we'll use slash
help
okay now you can see
let's start to start the board that we
have done help and eco
you put a message back to you so we'll
write
I don't write back so we'll write slash
Echo hi
then he has given us the output that is
high
so we can write slash eco
how are you
so it has given you back and same we
have slash caps so let's slash caps
anyone write something in small caps
that would be
greatly built
okay now you can see it has returned in
caps
so you can add some more functionality
to it and before that I will
get you guys understood the code
so now we'll see what does this code do
so first we have imported the necessary
modules that is the classes from the
python telegram board Library
that will need to create our board so
thallium contains the main board class
while updater command Handler message
handle and filter circles that we use to
handle incoming updates and messages
from Telegram
okay
now these are like we have created an
instance of the board class that is
using our telegram boot API token as
well as an updater instance that will
continuously fetch new updates from
Telegram and pass them to the
appropriate handlers
and we have used context equal to true
that tells the updater to use the new
context based API introduced in version
12 of the Python telegram board Library
and we also used a dispatcher object
that would handle incoming updates
after that we have created a start
function and passed update and context
so we have defined a function that will
handle the start command
and
the update parameter contains
information about the incoming update
from telegram while the context
parameter contains some useful methods
and objects that we can use to interact
with the telegram API
in this case we have used contact Port
dot send dot standard underscore message
to send a message to the chat with the
ID specified by update dot effective
underscore chat dot ID
and after that we have created a help
function
so we use a multi-line string to define
the help message which contains a list
of available commands
and then we have used the context.port.s
and underscore message to send the help
message to the chat
and after that we have the
Eco function
so we use context dot arguments to get
the message sent by the user after the
slash Eco command so to use this we have
to use the slash Echo and after that we
have to write the message and then use
join to join the message back together
to a single string we then we have used
the context.bot DOT send underscore
message to send the message back to the
chat then we have caps so this function
defines that will handle the Caps
command and we have again used the
context dot arguments to get the message
sent by the user after the slash caps
command
and then the we have used the upper
function to convert the message to all
caps and then we have user context dot
board dot send underscore message to
send the message back to the chat
then we have unknown function
that is this function defines that will
handle any command that the board
doesn't recognize so we have used
context.port.send
so it will just say sorry
okay so these are the start Handler help
Handler Eco Handler and caps Handler
so these are the commands
and we have the
we have added the add analog and to
start the board we have used update dot
start underscore polling
so this is how we have created the port
with the help of python and charge
Tubidy
so
we are done with the project you can add
more functionalities also
to the board you can just ask chat jbt
to get more functionalities to play
music in the telegram board or you could
just ask him how to send messages to a
particular user by the port only
and you could also
send media files ask the media files
from the board
and you can train a fully board by the
help of charge APD and this is called
chat GPT scripting so with the help of
chat Jeopardy you can just ask him and
he will guide you with all the code and
processes you just have to
like make them in a sequence and use
them too full of your use
so for that
first we will open the command prompt
and run the file
Main
for that
write the command go run
main.com so this is the file that is
written in the go language
and we're gonna run with the command
gorun main.com for that you need to have
colang installed on your system
so I will guide you with all the process
but currently we are seeing the demo so
here this command will generate a QR
code that will scan with the device
which we want to integrate the chat GPT
on so we'll wait for the file to get
executed and after this we will execute
the server.py file and that will open
the chat Jeopardy on the Firefox browser
you can also use other browsers that is
chromium and other if you want but we'll
use Firefox to skip the one step
verification that chatgifty ask us
whether if we are a bot or a human so we
will run the file again as there was
some error
so this time yeah it runs perfectly now
we'll take the device and open WhatsApp
on it in which we want to integrate the
charge APD so I am using one device to
just capture this QR code
so this is the device
and you can see that my device has
captured this QR code and you can see
here that WhatsApp me m e o w
it has been activated so now we'll run
another file that is server.py file and
that is the python file for that we'll
open the command prompt again and that
would be another command prompt and to
run that file we write the command
python
server.py
and you can see
in the Firefox browser jbt has opened
and I have logged in already so we
didn't it didn't ask me to login again
now
we will take another device and with
message on the mobile device which has
been integrated with the charge meeting
so from this device
I will write hi
and you can see on the screen that
chargity replies hello how can I assist
you today and the same you could see on
the WhatsApp chat so today we will ask
chair GPT
what is the capital of
India so you can see that the charge
repeating is typing
the capital of India is New Delhi and it
has been responded to
our mobile device so this is how
we can integrate chargpt on a WhatsApp
and this would be the simple tutorial in
this you don't need to code any
this there would be another tutorial if
you know what's behind the
code or what behind the integration part
so you could
watch that video and know how we have
integrated but in this tutorial I will
guide you with how to download the files
and how to run the files and how you can
integrate chargeability on your device
to start integrating chair GPT on our
device so for that first you have to
download this repository and it contains
some files and I will upload some more
files here you just have to download it
download the zip file
and after downloading it
you just need to extract it in a folder
so we will extract and
C drive in Python projects
mainly we create the folder here only so
here we'll create a folder
okay integrate charge obtain WhatsApp
mean or yeah
right integrate
checked chip it that's it
so inside this folder we'll extract the
files and I think it's been done
so we'll just visit
C drive python projects and inside it we
have integrate chat repeating and we
have these two files so to run these two
files what you need is you need python
installed on your system and golang
install your node system so I hope you
guys know how to install Python and
golang if you don't I will just give you
a quick tutorial
so to download the
python you just need to visit the
python.org website and move to the
download section and you will see the
download the latest version for Windows
you just need to click that
and the download will start for you the
package has been downloaded so I will
provide you the link on how to download
the
python in the description box and also
the link for the GitHub repository
so you don't have to search it anywhere
also you can search it on the browser
just write integrate charge update in
WhatsApp and abisa rahuja you will get
the GitHub link and just write GitHub
also in the search bar you will just
redirect it to
this
and now you have downloaded the python
so just open the exe file
and start with the installation so you
can choose add
python.exa to path
you can choose that
and
customize installation
and just click on the python test suit
and the next you can add the python to
environment variables so you have to
take both these options
and then you will click on the install
as I have already installed it so I
won't need to install it again you just
need to click on the install button and
here you will get the python installed
okay
and the other thing you need is golang
go language so to download it you have
to go sorry you have to go to its
official website and go to the download
section and here you will see the
Microsoft Windows as I am working on the
Windows operating system so I will
download for the windows I've already
downloaded and installed it so you guys
can download it
and I will show you like this is simple
how to install colon you don't need to
add anything so it's been downloaded
okay
to guide to the installation okay
so we are just waiting for the setup to
be initialized so that
we can install it
now you can see the next button is
available just click on that
and a previous version of Google
programming is currently installed yes
you can see that it's already installed
so you don't need to do anything in
installing the go language just click on
install and it would be installed for
you
so I won't be installing it again as I
already installed on my device
so moving on now what we'll do
first we will run the server.py file
so for that
we will go to the folder where we have
extracted our files and here we'll open
the command prompt
and
run the file server.py so to run a
python file we have to write the command
Python and then the name of the file
that is server and its extension that is
py so we have
initiated that
okay uh Firefox is already running as we
have node
closed but we have opened for the demo
I think
it's an error
I will
again
the current prompt I will just close the
previous command prompts
yeah I have
closed them
now I will open the new one and you
should open the command prompt
the new command prompt after installing
the Python and the code language I will
also assist you in
installing the GCC compiler because you
would be needing that for go language
so first we'll
run the server file
so you could see that by running the
python server.py file
you could see that the charge GPT has
opened up in the Firefox browser
so I will show you the code
what we need for that you need to
install the flask
system OS modules
playwright module
and here
in the 16th line you could see that we
have used Firefox you could use chromium
for Chrome but the case is you need to
do the one step verification that is the
captcha thing for
a colleague
initializing the charge repeating but we
don't need that so we are using the
Firefox so you should have Firefox on
your system
now what I want you to do is just
install these modules as if you if these
modules would not be installed on your
system it would show an error it would
give you an error in the command prompt
only as I have already installed them so
it's not giving me any error
so I will tell you the commands to
install them
[Music]
so to install flask you can just write
pypi space flask in any browser and it
will direct to the website
so you could open the first link that
would be pypi.org and this is a command
pip install flask so you can just copy
that
and open your command prompt first we'll
create it Ctrl C
and
now you could see that we are in the
folder integrate chat repeat and here
you could paste this command and press
enter
it states that that the requirement is
already satisfied as I have already
installed these modules
and the other module you need is
playwright so just copy the command go
to the command prompt and paste this
command
and press enter it would be installed
for you and another
what you need is virtual environment
so just copy this and paste in your coin
prompt and another module you need is
the OS module
OS
SOS system and we'll open the py pi
that is the official website the PIP
command website and you just copy the
command
go to your command prompt
paste the command and press enter and
this module would also be installed for
you guys and now you have installed the
go language the Python language and the
modules you need to run the server.py
file now what you need to do is run the
go file but before running the golang
file what you need is
GCC compiler so to download it
I will provide you the link for the GCC
or you could just see here I'll provide
you the link in the description box
below you could just click on that
you will be directed to this page just
click on this release that was 24th May
and what you need to download is this 64
plus 32-bit
just download it
and as it gets downloaded just open it
and click on the create button
and after that the second option then
next and the directory you want to
install in
as I already installed this
I will choose
the C directory only
in C
I would
install in Python projects okay
okay it didn't
took the folder
in C
oh sorry I can sell it
in Python projects and
in this same folder that was integrate
charity
okay
so I'll click on next
there's no time to install that yes I
want to install here and when you click
on install it would get installed for
you guys I've already installed it
started so it will get installed again
so now what you have to do is you have
got the
all the requirements to integrate the
chat Jeopardy on WhatsApp that is all
the modules for the server.py file and
the main.co file for that you have
installed the go language and the GCC
compiler so you could run both the files
and for that
we will close the command prompts and
open the new command prompts
and this is a
folder
so we will open one command prompt here
sorry
and we have to open different command
prompts for both the files for the
golang file and the python file okay
so we will open the command from tab and
now to run the Google link file we need
to write the command go space run space
the name of the file and the extension
that is main.co
and we have executed the file and this
file will provide us with a QR code and
we'll scan the square Port from our
first device in which we want to
integrate the chart GPD
and before that
we will run or another file that is
server.py file and for that we'll open
another command prompt
and to run this command
and to run this file we'll write the
command python space the name of the
file that is server and the extension.py
so we will see whether a QR code is
generated or not
and I can see
that it's been linked to
the previous device as we have done in
the demo so we haven't logged it
out
so I will check with the device yeah
it's mean active so I will just
log out from that device
and run it again
or I will open another command prompt to
run the golang file again
so to prevent it
will open the command prompt and write
the command CMD for that
and here we'll write the command to run
the
go file
and we have done that
and if we see the server.py file
yeah
has been
perfectly executed
but you're not able to
yeah all right
everybody is running fine now what we
have to do is
use our first device to scan this QR
code so that chatubity
gets linked to our first device and then
we'll use another device
to chat with the church
so now we have opened our first device
and open the WhatsApp and click on the
link devices
and here
I'm going to scan this QR code
and you can see that it's logging in
now it's logged in
and now from the another device
will ask a query to charge everybody
and we'll ask chargpt to write a code
to add two integers
and that one python
so we just misspelled python but we hope
that our chair GPT
understood that
so here we can see that the judge
everybody got the command
and it has
random good example so here's an example
called to add 20 teachers and python
has been integrated and we'll see
its response yeah we got the response
and now we'll ask another question and
that would be
what is the currency of United States
let's see what it responds the Grandeur
of the United States is the United
States dollar it is the most commonly
used currency in international
transaction and in other words primary
Reserve currency
so we can see that till it writes all
the lines holds and lenses it's been
executed on the browser and after it
completes or it stops generating the
answer
it sends it to the WhatsApp chat
so here
we are done with a project
now you guys have understood how to
integrate chat geometry with WhatsApp
and what you have done is we have
downloaded the repository and we have to
extract all the files that are present
in the repository I will update all the
files you just have to extract them into
a folder and then run the main.co file
and the server.py file and before
executing these files you need to have
golang and python installed on your
system and for the python you need some
modules that we have seen that is the
playwrite module The Flash module the OS
system module and the virtual
environment module so we have seen how
to install them and when you will just
execute the file on the command prompt
you would get errors if these files or
modules are not installed on your system
and for golang we have installed the GCC
compiler and after installing all these
requirements then you have to just run
both the files and when you run the
golang file you will get the QR code
just scan it with your device on which
you want to integrate the chat APD and
after that from any device you can just
message on that number on which you have
integrated the charity and the child GPT
would answer all your queries we are
going to automate WhatsApp using python
by pivotkit library and with the help of
chat chipity and before starting
I have a quiz question for you guys
and your question is
how much did meta that is formerly
Facebook spend to acquire WhatsApp in
2014 and your options are your first
option is dollar 10 billion dollars
second option is 19 million dollars
third option is 20 billion dollars and
the fourth option is 21 billion orders
please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the pin comment you can pause
the video give it a thought and answer
in the comment section
so moving on
now will move to create a project
so first we will create a folder for a
project
and for that we will
create a folder in
python projects
and windows
automate WhatsApp
using chat jbd
okay and inside this we'll open the
command prompt
and open our ID
that is we want to automate the mode
step using Python and with the help of
chat Deputy we won't write the code on
our own we will ask chargpt to automate
it
we will create the file and name it as
main.py
and now we'll move to chat jpd
and ask chat jbt
to write a code to send messages through
WhatsApp using Python and the pivot kit
Library
so we will give a command send message
through
WhatsApp using
Python and
private kit
let's see but
chat jpd response to us and we have also
created the automate WhatsApp using
python video
I will just Link in the I button you can
check that out
and we'll see what
chat jpd tells us okay
[Music]
country code message
minutes yeah it could work
and first you need to install the
pivotkit library
terminal or command prompt okay replace
Target phone number with the Target
phone number you want to send the
message to country code with the country
code of the Target phone number message
with the message you want to send r with
the rn24r format and you want to send
message and minute with the minute you
want to send the message okay for
example
yeah okay
all right so we'll copy this code
and
paste
in our ID
but before that
first you need to install a pivot kit
library and for that you can go to the
command prompt and
write the command
pip
space install space
pivot kit and press enter
it states that the requirement is
already satisfied as I've already
installed this module and you can
install it by writing the simple command
and you will get it installed and if you
face any error installing it just
comment down
and would be very happy to resolve your
queries
Okay so
as chat GPT States we will just enter
the
things it won't promise so it's asking
the Target phone number and the country
code without plus sign
okay
so here we'll just
write all the things but as you can see
it has also given us an example
to see
and work on the code
so here
we'll just clear it
I will write the phone number to whom I
want to send the message
so it would be
and I would just blur this number so you
guys
won't be able to see okay
and here will just
add the country code
and that is without plus sign
okay
so my country code is
you can search it that is I live in
India
and the message I want to send to Ms
hello
how are you
and now
we'll set the
RN minute so the current time is 15 14.
set
16. okay
we'll save this
and run it
so it says that the country code is
sync
so we'll just
copy the error and give it to chat jbd
as we are taking the help of chat
Jeopardy in this video
so he has given us the code so we'll
just provide the error to him let's see
but it states if it's not able
to resolve this then we will resolve it
[Music]
um
and then the phone number you're trying
to send okay
yes and the country code is now I'm
going to send the message correctly you
need to make sure
okay
um one two three four five six seven
eight nine
you mentioned
provide that phone number is this and
the country code is nine one okay
you need to make sure the country code
is refreshed to the phone number like
this
two three four five six seven eight nine
okay we don't have to make testing
yeah no
we will turn it again
okay it's a string only
so I will write the phone number again
yes
three
okay now we'll see
what I will do
I will write the country code here we'll
save this
and the time is 15 17 now so we'll just
22 15 18.
save this and run it
so our code has been executed
successfully that is in 20 seconds
WhatsApp will open and after 15 seconds
message will be delivered
so we just have to see that
we have enter the time as 15 18. is the
seconds
have level four
the code to get executed yeah
it has opened the WhatsApp
it will take time as my WhatsApp has
loads of chats and contacts
here I have to scan it
don't think
it would be a as we have reached 15 18.
you have scanned it
let's see if it will deliver the message
or not
else we have to change the time
so we just have to wait for 15 seconds
let's see
okay
just stop the terminal
and run it again
4 15 21 so we'll
save this and run it again
so it states that in 85 seconds WhatsApp
will open and after 15 seconds message
will be delivered
so we'll get fast forwarded here
so we are still waiting
let's see when it will open the WhatsApp
okay it states that the phone number
shared by URL is invalid
okay I'll just check the phone number
again
[Music]
okay I entered the wrong phone number
sorry guys
oh I will just update the time again
and it would be 15 22. we'll make it
fast we'll run this
okay let's say that the call time must
be greater than so we'll at 15 23 7.
we will make the
time is 15 27
save it and run it
okay it states that's in 40 seconds
WhatsApp will open and after 15 seconds
message will be delivered
it has opened the WhatsApp
and it has started the chat
okay it has
to return the
and we have send it to hello how are you
that's good
on that note we present you postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning
elevate your professional journey by
enrolling in this Ai and ml course
presented through a partnership between
Purdue University and IBM hurry up and
enroll Now find the complete course
details from the link mentioned in the
description box below see how charging
Beauty can help you to make a great app
so here we have chargpt okay you can
write here chat dot openair.com
so here I will ask to charge gbt what is
chargeability so I will write what is
chat
so here you can stop generating if you
want to
okay I will stop generating okay so
charge bit is a conversational
artificial intelligence model developed
by open air it is based on the GPT
generative pretend transform
architecture specifically GPT 3.5 which
is at Advanced language model so GPT 3.5
is trained on a massive amount of tax
data to generate human like response to
wide range of problems and question
you can ask anything to charge GPT
okay
after coming
chat
GPT
[Music]
software
Developers
save
software developer jobs
say
Big Mountain see yes after the
introduction of Charity and similar
language model software developers still
have important roles and their jobs
remain regular while AI models like
chargpt can generate tax and provide
automated response they have limitations
see they have limitations charge gbt
have limitation and cannot replace the
skills and expertise of human software
Developers
so here is a few reasons why software
developer jobs remain valuable okay so
here are the few reasons so you can ask
anything to charge gbt
so what we will do we will create a
small small gaming app okay so here I
will write
uh
let's make first tic-tac-toe okay so
here I will write
give
me
the code
for tick
to
see it will give you the step by step
charity will explain you everything see
this board
then player check columns check
diagonals play game everything please
check for the winner play game
I will see to play the game simply run
the python script players will take
turns entering the row column numbers to
make their moves the game will
okay so what I will do okay first I will
ask the steps to make a game tic-tac-toe
okay
give
me
we will ask for these steps then we will
ask for the code
charge Beauty can make your app in 2-3
minutes in just 2-3 minutes small small
app in two three minutes
okay see what what is the first step set
up the game board create a data
structure to represent the tic-tac-toe
board this can be three by three Grid or
nested list with initial empty values
okay for example this then second is the
print the game board write a function to
display the current state of the board
on the screen this will help player
visualize the game
and the third is get player input prompt
the player to enter their moves except
the input for the rows and columns where
the players want to place their symbol X
or zero okay
or you can change the value X or 0
whatever cross right okay
update the board after receiving the
player input update the game board with
their move make sure to validate the
move and check if the selected position
is empty
okay then check for the winner then
check for it is draw word then alternate
turns
okay then repeat two to seven until the
game sends optional additional features
we will first we will make tic-tac-toe
uh what you can say a simple tic-tac-toe
then we will add the additional features
on this okay using charge GPT only okay
so
I will write
provide me the
tick
tag
to
game code
what we will do we will open the visual
studio and copy it directly
obviously current pair is X
then o
see currently Arrow the second player
switch player
okay what we will do we will copy it
from here and we will open see Visual
Studio that new file I will write here
take
tag 2 dot P1 okay Enter
I will save it so here I will directly
copy the code
where's my
it comes in
okay
copied this also
open the whole
okay I have to remove this or I can make
it you know comment
yeah
so let's try to run it
what terminal says
see enter the row
okay
to
enter the column
okay it made like this
okay
what I will do
I will ask for the GUI
provide me the
back to okay with GUI
okay now the Tinker came Tinker is
python Library used for the GUI in
Python
okay okay now uh
we'll copy the code and just paste it it
will run okay with GUI and then we will
add the additional features okay from
here now I'm copying the code
now select all replace with this code
like here no error no red sign so let me
play it
it will run I guess no problems
okay what happened see as you can see
we got the tic-tac-toe game
okay so see here x
0 x
0 x player X wins
so let me add the additional features in
this
so what we will do will
go to chatgpt again we'll ask for the
additional features see
load the code above uses the message box
module from the Tinker for displaying
messages ensure that you have compatible
version to think okay when you run this
quota graphical windows will appear by
three by three give and this okay
players can click on the buttons to make
their move the game instead will
okay
date you can you know talk to charity so
I will say update
my code with some
good
phone and scoreboard
scoreboard
font scoreboard and color
update my GUI code I can write
here is an update see like certainly
here is an updated version of GUI code
with improved font scoreboard and color
if you get error in this you can ask to
charge GPT okay
anything you are facing issue about your
code whatever it is you can ask directly
to chat GPT
see we created an App in like two
minutes just in two minutes
so charge gbt is making our life easier
okay let me copy this code
okay
let's see the changes
what WhatsApp charge videos
okay
this is nothing changed I guess
player expense like this cross
okay
I will write here
see in this updated code the font style
has been improved with a bold aerial
font the buttons have a custom
background color and the overall window
and discover have a different color
oh I didn't feel like this
I didn't feel like this
okay so
change
the
did it time
of the
game
it's giving updating the boat
seem to change the greatest set of the
same you can modify variance of the
buttons and the spacing between them is
an updated version jio I go to the
modified register
it's just a little bit of time taking
that's it nothing else it's very useful
third Zippity you can create your app in
2-3 minutes
only
okay
continue generating it's a half code
okay code is copied
let me select and paste it here
and check see
player x 0 player row zero
okay it's a little bit different I guess
okay this one two three box why these
lines
okay who cares
that expense okay see the scoreboard is
updated
okay
so this is how you can make your
tic-tac-toe more beautiful
okay let me write here
let me write here I want the black and
white boxes okay or colorful boxes
so
um
code
provide me the code for the
colorful
boxes
okay
okay here
GPD Road certainly here is an updated
version of the code with colorful boxes
instead of grid lines
okay
so we're waiting for the code update the
code
see in this updated code each player's
button X and O has a specific color
assigned to it the button colors okay
let me
copy the code and paste it here
and run it
see the color is changed
and let's see X
o x o x o x
player expense
okay so this is how you can make your
app more beautiful beautiful using
customization you can ask share GPT
anything color style font or any
function
anything you can ask and you you can
make your app
more beautiful okay
so now let's move on to the next game
which I want a snake game okay using pi
game we will make
so here I will write please provide
me the code
oh
snake
game
using
Spy game python
okay
everyone knows what is his name game
or first you want to ask the steps we
can ask the steps okay after this I will
ask this step
okay
so till then let's make a new file of
snake
game Dot py
okay
close it
see it's a long
code I guess just continue generating
now you can see that see the food and
all will come okay
you can ask anything like any question
any language question
this code sets up the basic structure
for this game using pi game it include
the functionality for displaying the
snake controlling this movement
detecting collision with the boundaries
and food and managing the score you can
run the code and play the snake game
with buy game window feel free to
customize see
feel free to customize and enhance the
game according your preference okay that
is what I was talking about
you can change
n number of times you can ask n number
of times for the code new new code
okay
there is fun why this error is coming
import buy game could not be resolved by
lens
what is the Spy lens okay let me ask to
charge the video only
what is
violence
is a language server for python
developed by Microsoft which provides
the one's language features including
code completion type checking
static analysis and code navigation
cavity pylons is built on the top of
language server okay
let me give the error itself
copy message
okay
I will write debug error
file lens
okay
make sure you have a pi game installed
Pi game is already installed on my
who can study on a python environment
open your command prompt terminal
and run the following command okay let
me open the command prompt
okay then what I have to write
we copy the code
and paste it here
what is this
okay emergency this is this
if Pi game is not installed you can
re-install by running
already installed I guess
we'll ensure the pylons is using the
correct python to verify that balance is
considered to use the sample which you
have installed by a game you can check
the python interpreter setting in your
code
editor or ID visual make sure it's point
to correct path environment Wi-Fi game
is installed
okay
what I will do
I will go to terminal and here I will
write
babe
install
Empire
it will be helpful
okay let me do this
pip installed by game
okay successfully install new pip
some error of Pi aim I guess okay we'll
run it online no worries
won't work in this I will run it online
okay
see the requirement is already
satisfying this this this
so what we will do we will open
the plate okay
we'll open the plate and we'll create
the new rapple
okay that python
and created
okay this is the same like you know one
of the
IDE you can say
then what I will
I will copy the space code
and paste it here
okay I will make a new file it's name
Dot py
okay on that I will copy the code and I
will run it
okay
the upgrade updating the package and the
project and the buy game
okay it's running the code is running
okay it's installing Pi game
okay let me run now
what happened what's the error
what's the error
okay
okay some hello from PI game Community
this is
some game Loop module file main.pln
okay
we'll ask to charge GPT
[Music]
code showing
better
okay
provide
me the
game code using
python
Julie
this time from Turtle okay
let's see
because the pi games I don't know Pi
game is installed on my system it's not
working
so we will leave it
okay we'll ask from this some good gy
with some good GI
see it is the head everything is the
keyboard bindings from wsd or you can up
down left right the keys
you can use from use the both okay
continue generating
then the functions the pen the snake
body everything is a snake head is like
everything is here what you want
everything is here
see the code utilize the turtle module
to create the basic game with the snake
that moves collect for the the score
just did
okay feel free to
let me copy the code
let me copy here only
and run it
see this is the snake
okay this is the food this is the score
or high score okay I will run it
okay
okay see
you can customize your snake your food
everything see the score
previous time the score was then the
high score now it changes
okay the score is 30 now I am enjoying
the game
so this is how you can customize your
you know game
to play the game
okay see this is how you can make any
game or any small small game in two two
three three minutes okay
so uh go to chatgpt and you want the you
know change the color of the snake or
the food anything you can do using chat
GPT
okay artificial intelligence large
language models and AI chatbots have
come a long way and today we have many
AI language models which are helping us
throughout various domains few examples
are Microsoft's Bank Google's bar open
AIS chart GPT Megatron T5 and many more
today we will be discussing about the
caliber of chat jbd and AI which can
leverage you and help you to build a
perfect business so few of the reasons
that you need to consider are the
decision making capabilities of chat GPT
and AI customer services that you can
offer through chat GPT and AI chat GPT
potential to create a content and its
potential to leverage data analysis and
charge gbts and AI capabilities to
provide sales and marketing for you and
run automation for you we will discuss
each one of these in detail so the first
one is decision making capabilities of
chat GPT in terms of raw processing
speed chat GPT can analyze and generate
text at a rapid base capable of
processing and generating responses much
faster than a human can type or think it
can quickly access and retrieve
information from its pre-trained
knowledge providing intermediate answers
to suggestions therefore chart GPT
excels in processing and generating text
at higher speeds however it cannot be
directly compared to humans in terms of
decision making abilities however it is
proof that it is 90 accurate in addition
making whereas humans tend to be
accurate at a rate of 80 to 85 percent
charge GPT is anyways stronger in terms
of decision making at this case followed
by that moving ahead to the next reason
that is the customer service that Char
gbd and AI can help you with if you
compare a human the customer support
representative reads the customer care
compared human the customer support
representative has to read the
customer's query analyze the problem and
formulate a response this process may
take a few minutes or more depending on
the complexity of the issue and
representatives typing speed right but
when you compare it with chart GPD the
AI power chatbot like chatgpt quickly
scans and comprehends the customer's
query it generates a response within
milliseconds providing intermediate
assistance as well so chatgpt's
proficient atom providing customer
services at a much faster rate and it
can also eliminate you the cost of
hiring training and maintaining an
entire Army of customer services moving
ahead we have content creation if you
are a startup company or a company which
needs content creation for your product
then obviously you might end up hiring
Freelancers or a team of content
creators right but compared to humans
charge GPS is proficient at generating
content and can produce coherent and
contextually relevant text so you can
even save money by using the most
powerful and fully operational AI model
to create more versatile and highly
qualified content for you to avoid
hiring Freelancers and employees now
moving ahead the next reason is using AI
models for business data analysis AI can
assist you in data analysis by
leveraging its computational power and
advanced algorithms to possess and
extract valuable insights from large and
complex data sets AI algorithms can
automate data cleaning pattern
recognition and anomaly detection tasks
enabling faster and more accurate
results AI models can also perform
Predictive Analytics identifying Trends
and making forecasts based on historical
data additionally AI can facilitate data
visualization presenting information in
intuitive and interactive formats for
better understanding by automating
repetitive tasks and augmenting human
capabilities AI enhances the proficiency
efficiency accuracy and scalability of
data analysis procedures you can rely on
AI language model to extract transform
and load data and analyze your business
data and generate reports draw
projections and make data driven
decisions to help grow your company and
this also Awards you to hire and
maintain a huge Army of data analysts
which may produce some or the other
errors in real time right and next
reason is sales and marketing chat GPD
can leverage sales and marketing efforts
in the following ways customer
engagement chargpt can engage with
potential customers and real time
answering their queries providing
product information and guiding them
through sales process it enhances
customer experience by delivering prompt
and personalized responses next is later
generation charge GPT can act as a
virtual assistant collecting and
qualifying leads by interacting through
website visitors it can gather relevant
information access customer needs and
provide initial assistance generating
valuable needs for the sales team 24 7
support charge gpt's ability to operate
Around the Clock allows for continuous
customer support it can address
inquiries or for product recommendations
and resolve issues even outside regular
business hours improving customer
satisfaction and retention now instead
of hiring a team and manually marketing
your product on social media platforms
and spending thousands of dollars to run
paid marketing you can use a models to
crack the algorithms and Market the
product to your target audience with
that let's proceed to the next reason
that is automating your tasks charge upd
can automate business procedures in the
following ways the first one being
customer service charge APD can handle
customer inquiries Provide support and
resolve common issues through automated
chat interactions it reduces need for
human intervention saves time and
enables 24 7 customer support lead
qualifications chat GPT can engage with
potential customers ask qualifying
questions and and gather information to
assess their suitability as leads it
automates the initial stages of lead
qualification enabling sales team to
focus on most promising prospects only
next is data entry and processing chat
GPT can automate data entry tasks by
extracting relevant information from
various sources such as forms emails or
documents it reduces manual effort
improving accuracy and speeds up the
data processing appointment scheduling
charge GPD can integrate with scheduling
systems allowing customers to book
appointments or schedule meetings
automatically
finally workflow automation charge GPD
can integrate with business systems and
automated workflows it can initiate
actions send notifications or trigger
processes based on predefined rules
streamlining operations and improving
efficiency by automating various tasks
and processes chat Equity enhances
productivity reduces operational costs
and frees up human resources for
focusing on higher value activities with
their business so these were the few
important ways and reasons why charge
GPT and AI can help you make your
business is to generate passive income
without putting in too much effort
thanks to the advancement in artificial
intelligence and chat boards it's now
possible to earn money using these
Technologies in this video we'll explore
some of the effective ways to generate
passive income with Charity charity is
known for being the world's smartest
generative Ai and is changing the game
when it comes to making money online
with this revolutionary free tool you
can earn with little skill and no
capital require there is an exciting New
Era of artificial intelligence and now
is the perfect time to get involved and
take advantage of this opportunity
people are using chat Jeopardy for
YouTube blogging freelancing and for
many other ways to make money so let's
dive in and discover how to make money
using chat Jeopardy and generate various
passive incomes there are variety of
ways that you can make money using chat
Jeopardy we'll discuss few of them in
this video and we'll start with first
we'll see the list of all the ideas from
which you can make money the first is
get business ideas from chat Jeopardy
second is freelancing third is build a
software fourth is boost your affiliate
marketing with chat Jeopardy's email
expertise with this leverage charge
ability for blogging success then access
unlock the potential of charge Deputy
for affiliate marketing and then we have
utilized chat jbd for ebook writing and
self-publishing this is the main thing
what people are doing to make money
using charitability and then we have
utilized chat everybody to enhance your
YouTube channel and then we have writing
lyrics for music so starting them one by
one we'll start with get business ideas
from chargeability by getting to know
your interest talent and obstacles chat
jpd can generate tailored business
Concepts that align with your
expectations let's Dive Right In and ask
chat Jeopardy for some business ideas
for a computer science engineer who has
experience in digital marketing and
sales chat repeating and ask him that I
am a
computer science graduate the computer
science engineer
with experience in sales and marketing
and what side Hustle
should I start
generate
around thousand dollars to generate
thousand dollars
income that would be per day
and that would be with minimum
investment amount
and this is
minimum investment
and I can also tell him how many hours I
can dedicate so I can dedicate it
to 10 hours
to this side Hustle
press enter
so you could see that chat Jeopardy
replies us that as a computer science
engineer with expense and sales and
marketing there's several side of Health
two generate thousand dollars income per
day
and he has stated the first one is
e-commerce then affiliate marketing
digital products you can create and sell
digital products such as ebooks okay
freelancing social media management and
YouTube channel you can start your
YouTube channel
so these are the ideas that you can get
from chat Jeopardy and but these ideas
tailored to user skills and interests
that I have put in now it's time to take
these ideas and discuss them further
with chat Jeopardy to conceptualize a
plan so consider important factors like
alternatively you can begin by stating
generate a new business idea poor
digital products you can write that and
he will guide you how you can start it
or you could just write
can you elaborate
the business
idea
of
digital
products
I am on
to start the side
hustle with this
and then you press enter and you can see
that it has started
the process for the business idea
certainly starting a side as well
centered around digital products can be
lucrative and fulfilling Venture
identify your expertise
it manure areas of knowledge skills and
passion and then he has stated choose
your product format create valuable
content set up an online platform Market
your products build an audience optimize
for conversions provide excellent
customer support so these are the parts
he has stated and moreover you can
elaborate those parts also you can just
ask chat Deputy so how can I identify my
expertise and he will guide you with
that so you can go deep down and explore
any business idea so this was the first
method through which you can generate
income from chat equity and moving on
the next would be freelancing so take
your freelancing game to the next level
with chair Jeopardy this state of the
art AI tool is enabling professionals to
earn extra income and produce top
quality content that pose clients
companies are even offering incentives
for those who utilize this technology to
create polished well researched work so
here are some freelance services that
you can offer using chatgpt
starting with you can write blog or
website content using chatgpt for others
you can translate any language with
chatgpt you can craft compelling
headlines and calls to action with chat
GPT and moreover you can do create
social media content for posts or
marketing for other people or any
advertising agency you can write
captivating short stories using chat
deputy and you can conduct hashtag
research using chatributing that is you
can find what is trending and offer your
services to other people and gain money
so these are the ways in which you could
freelance and have some money in your
pockets so you could just write a
command that would be write a blog post
and
you could write on any topic that would
be write a blog post on
U.S economy
so you could use this AI tool as your
means like with the what your client
required you can use for that and write
the perfect without plagiarism content
that would be blog post and you can
translate any language with chai triputi
you can write
competitive headlines and calls and you
can also write social media content that
would be you can use SEO research for
that and you can write short stories
also see that he has given you the blog
post on the topic U.S economy the
navigating uh the title is navigating
the current state of the U.S economic
Trends and insights and you can see that
it has given you six points and if you
want more you can just ask him to
elaborate
elaborate this
and I've found this blog post
in 800 words
so the thing you just have to do is
write the script write the prompt you
have to just prompt scripting and that
too in the easy language that is in
English and you will get all your
answers from the chat jpd
so now it will write the blog post that
would be in 800 words
so
it's good and moving on
what we'll do let's check out one of our
Learners what he has to say about our
courses we need to keep updating your
skills on a regular basis no matter what
level you're at I recently completed the
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning from Simply learn
in partnership with Purdue University
the course material was comprehensive
and the faculty was extremely
experienced The Faculty was able to
adjust their teaching style in order to
cater to the overall skill set of the
class in the rapidly evolving world of
technology it's important to keep up
Skilling for every working professional
stay relevant continue learning now
coming back so the third passive income
you could make using charge up it is
building a software imagine this
scenario you have an issue with your
online business
and you realize that many other people
are facing the same problem well here's
where chair deputy comes to the rescue
you can utilize chair Jeopardy to create
software using report provided by the AI
and then you can sell these software
tools to make money it's as simple as
that by leveraging chat Jeopardy's
powerful capabilities you can develop
innovative solutions to common problems
and turn them into valuable software
tools whether it's automating a task
streamlining a process or providing a
unique service the possibilities are
endless once you have created your
software tools you can Market them to
your target audience researching out to
those who can benefit from your solution
and guess what people are always looking
for convenient and efficient software
tools to enhance their business so
there's a ready Market waiting for you
so selling software tools not only
allows you to earn a steady income but
also impose others to overcome
challenges and improve their own
Ventures it's a win-win situation so if
you are a problem solver and have a
knack of four coding why not use charge
ability to create software tools that
can make a real happy start by
identifying common pain points that also
you can ask from chat Jeopardy you can
just ask the chat jpt I want to create a
software to help others during or in
online processes in online e-commerce so
he'll give you suggestions and then you
can proceed with those suggestions and
create a software and then you can sell
it or you can use for your own use
so now and press the power chat jpt tap
into its coding expertise and unlock the
potential to create and sell software
tools so your journey to financial
success starts right here and moving on
we'll move to the next income source
that we can gain from chat jbd so you
can boost your affiliate marketing with
chat Jeopardy's email expertise so do
you know that charity processes
exceptional writing skills it's true
this incredible chatbot can drop
convincing emails that motivate users to
take action whether it's clicking on
affiliate links making purchases or
subscribing to Services charitivity has
caught you power that's impressive
ability to generate engaging content you
can Captivate your audience and compel
them to take the desired actions so
we'll get back to the chat GPT and ask
him that
I am an email marketer
and you need to
sell my CRM software
so right
an email
only
so I can attract
customer
and make them bite
okay
now you could see that it is writing
email for you and you can launch your
email affiliate marketing campaign also
now that we understand the power of
child supporting let's discuss how you
can Kickstart your email affiliate
marketing campaign the first step is to
choose an affiliate program that aligns
with your Niche whether it's Amazon's
Spotify Shopify convertkit or any other
program make sure it suits your target
audience next it's time to build an
email list of potential customers who
are generally interested in your
promoted products or Services you can
use lead magnets or employ other
effective methods to encourage email
signups you could see that he has
written the email that is I hope this
email finds you well as an email
marketed person okay this is for me and
you could start from here at your
company we have developed a powerful CRM
solution reload specifically for email
marketers like yourself our software
combines Advanced features user friendly
okay here is written for uh email
marketers only as targeted audience that
is email marketer no issue you can ask
him to change that and like you can
craft compelling emails with chair
Jeopardy and this is where chat Jeopardy
truly shines with its assistance you can
create highly engaging emails that not
only inform users about the benefits of
the products but also Inspire them to
click on your affiliate links and make
purchases imagine having a chat about by
your side imagine having a chatbot by
your side helping you write captivating
emails effortlessly by incorporating
persuasive language compelling
storytelling and personalized touch your
emails will stand out in crowded inboxes
and generate higher click-through rates
so this is how chat Jeopardy can help
you in email marketing now the next
method is leverage child Jeopardy for
blogging success in the realm of
blogging chair Jeopardy offers an array
of advantages that can elevate your
content creation Journey so the first is
content generation so Unleash the Power
of this AI driven tool to spank your
creativity and overcome writer's block
chat GPT assist bloggers by generating
ideas crafting outlines anyone providing
complete routes for blog posts say
goodbye to our spend on research the
charge Deputy you can access relevant
information statistics and facts and
mere seconds elevate your blogging game
and Unleash Your Potential with this an
invaluable source
and then you can add it and proofread
using charge update if you have written
any content and get any content written
you could just write what we have
already written that was write a blog
post on U.S economic that we have seen
in freelancing uh side Hustle but here
you can write and not only write but
also if you have added some points with
your research you can proofread and edit
by using chargpt that is for bloggery
proves to be a valuable asset by
offering assistance in editing
proofreading and enhancing the overall
readability of your blog post it
provides suggestions and Corrections for
spelling grammar and comprehension
reducing errors and ensuring Clarity
let's chat Jeopardy Define your writing
and ensure a blog post shine with
professionalism the next what you can do
for a blogging journey is keyword
research and SEO optimization so this is
a fundamental aspect of successful
blogging chargipti becomes your trusted
companion in optimizing your blog post
for search engines it suggests relevant
keywords to include guides you on a
structure in your content for maximum
visibility and offer steps to enhance
your online presence maximize your blogs
reach and attract more organic traffic
in chat GPS SEO expertise and then we
have audience engagement and I will also
show you how we can relate keywords so
for SEO you could just search that would
be
gaming related
SEO keywords
for and the topic would be online
shopping
and press enter so here are some related
SEO keywords for online shopping you
could see all these you would mention
these on your backlinks if you have
website or you could add into your blog
posts hashtags which can gain you rank
when searched so moving back the next
was audience engagement so engaging your
audience is key to building a thriving
blow charity can assist you in
connecting with the readers on a deeper
level it provides conversation starters
answer common questions and addresses
concerns from your Audience by
leveraging Charity's capabilities you
can post on meaningful interactions
cultivated lower following and force
lasting connections with your readers by
harnessing the power of charge Deputy
bloggers can consistently produce high
quality content Captivate their target
audience bolster their online presence
and generate passive income embrace the
potential of char Jeopardy and embark on
an exciting blog Journey it will leave a
lasting impact so moving on we will now
see another side herself that is unlock
the potential of chair Jeopardy for
affiliate marketing and you could do
easily affiliate marketing if you have
this blogging thing
so affiliate marketing opens up a world
of earning possibilities and shared GPT
can be your trusted Ally on this
rewarding Journey users of charge Deputy
can leverage its capabilities to
generate income through affiliate
marketing this powerful tool provides a
seamless Avenue for promoting Goods
services and Brands all while learning a
commission based on resulting sales
embarking on an affiliate marketing
Venture requires thoughtful planning as
a blogger or content creator you must
carefully select the medium through
which you will build your audience
whether it's through captivating
articles engaging audio content or
compelling videos you have the freedom
to choose the format that aligns with
your strengths and resonates with your
target audience when you have
established your audience building
medium chair Deputy steps into support
your affiliate marketing efforts this AI
driven tool empowers you to craft
persuasive content that effectively
promotes the products or Services you
are affiliated with while collaborating
with chat Jeopardy you can tap into its
exceptional writing skills and create
captivating promotional materials that
resonate with with your audience as you
implement your affiliate marketing
strategy charity becomes an invaluable
resource it helps you to draft engaging
articles record compelling audio content
or script captivating videos that
highlight the benefits and value of the
products or services that you are
promoting so remember affiliate
marketing is a process that requires
dedication and perseverance through
consistent effort and support of chat
dipty you can unlock the potential of
earning substantial income by promoting
products and services that resonate with
your audience and this was for the
affiliate marketing and the next big
thing is utilize chair Jeopardy for
ebook writing and self-publishing so are
you a passionate writer seeking fresh
and innovative ideas look no further
charitivity revolutionizes your writing
experience in a recent report that
revealed that AI written ebooks have
experienced a remarkable search on
Amazon so you could just go and charge
deputy and ask him
I want to write a self
help book
add to
Black version free
okay I think yeah no spelling is correct
and H should have
resonating
chapters there's no needing
chapters
so
provide me
with a list of checkers
as you can see that
it will Define you and you can also ask
the title for the book and it will give
you the perfect title and you can see
the chapters that is introducing setting
a stage for personal growth discovering
your authentic self cultivating a
positive mindset and after that you can
ask chat Deputy to elaborate these
topics that would be in some words in
some pages and you can use the same
content to write a book and you can also
ask the title from the chat jpd
as you create a companion the
possibilities are boundless you don't
need to possess the skills of literary
genius to make an impact in the e-book
Market Kindle Direct publishing offers
seamless platform to Showcase your book
and make it easily accessible to
enthusiastic readers while leveraging
child Deputy to assist in writing your
ebook you will save precious time and
energy allowing you to concentrate on
marketing and promoting your work
effectively so this is how you can write
ebooks and generate income
using chair GPD moving on we have next
passive income that is utilized chargpt
to enhance your YouTube channel
is an invaluable tool that can assist
you in generating captivating video
ideas you can ask him the video ideas
also and this is the creative block
charge if you can even cool the extra
mile by creating a script for YouTube
videos
so let's tap into the creative pros and
we'll ask chair jpt I want to create a
YouTube video
on topic GDP
that is close domestic product and
I need your help
writing
the script for that
so you could see that chair jpd has
started its work
so it's fine welcome back to our channel
in today's video we'll be diving into
the fascinating world of Cubit GDP what
exactly is GDP and why is it such an
important measure of a country's economy
so you can see that it has created the
script for your YouTube video and it is
also telling you the scenes
so this is how you could leverage
Japanese capabilities and that can give
you YouTube channel a significant boost
helping you create engaging content and
capture the attention of your audience
so start exploring the possibilities
with chat Deputy today and witness your
channel thrive so moving on the next we
have is writing lyrics for music so when
it comes to music the words we use in
songs are super important they have the
power to make us feel all kinds of
emotions and connect with people and now
there's a cool tool called chargabity
that can help you write awesome song
lyrics with chat you can take your ideas
and turn them into beautiful words that
touch people's heart it's like having a
virtual writing buddy that help you come
up with catchy lines and cool Rhymes you
can play around with different ways to
express yourself and make your lyrics
stand out so you can chat GPT to write
lyrics for you the evolution of natural
language processing has come a long way
today we have a variety of AI language
models that are fully operational and
have the potential not just to decode
your question but also smart enough to
understand the intention behind your
questions are the countless number of
development and the emerging ones like
Megatron Albert Electra T5 and many more
these three models are currently ruling
the space of AI language models Bank
bird and charging and today we will
understand the differences similarities
and the abilities that make them stand
out and try to decide which one is the
best hey everyone welcome to Simply
launch YouTube channel and today we
bring you the Bing versus the Google bar
the chat GPD but before we begin if
these are the type of videos you would
like to watch hit that subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn if you are an
aspiring artificial intelligence
engineer looking for an online training
and certification from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts so that you have the
most robust Foundation skills knowledge
and what it takes to become the best
then search no more simply learns post
graduation program in artificial
intelligence from Purdue University in
collaboration with IBM should be your
right choice for more details use the
link in the description box below also
want to get access to more informative
content like this one get subscribed to
us and hit the Bell so that you are the
first to get to know when we host with
that in mind let's start with the
elephant in the room that is the chat
GPD
Chad GB was released on the 30th of
November 2022 it uses the GPT llm to
elaborate llm as an abbreviation for
large language model and chat jpd is
globally available to its users using
the generative pre-trained Transformer
also called as chat GPT llm with 1
trillion parameters as its variables
loaned during the model training
now the Bing
Microsoft was one of the largest
investors in open AI Bing is an AI
language model created in collaboration
with open Ai and publicly released on
the 4th of May 2023 Bing uses the same
data set that chat GPD uses Bing has an
edge over chart GPT as Microsoft
integrates its Prometheus with about 135
billion parameters now next up we have
Bard Bard is Google's answer to chat gbd
with limited capabilities and lukewarm
responses it was released on 21st of
March 2023 but initially started off
with Lambda llm with a caliber of 137
billion parameters Google's CEO eshos
Bard will switch to pathway model named
as palm 2 llm with about 400 billion
plus parameters to take on chat GPD
head-on head in generating responses and
the application codes and Pro
photographs with the details discussed
let's move ahead to some of the
important parameters to be considered to
discuss the differences firstly user
interface and experience chat GPD has a
simple and subtle interface making it
easy to understand and get along with
the usage so chat gpt's user interface
looks something like this chat GPT has a
simple Dark theme interface focusing on
providing users with high quality
language processing capabilities rather
than immersive visuals you can ask
questions get answers and even you can
ask to enhance or optimize the answer
according to your needs again user needs
to manually request chat GPD the other
hand Bing is more inclined towards
giving a blissful visual experience to
their users by choosing brilliant
background images colorful interfaces
and emojis
so a typical Wing user interface looks
something like this in addition to that
it is backed up by chat gpd's dataset
and Prometheus llm to help users with
the best in class answers to their
questions it even delivers three
different answers at the same time
creative balanced and precise are the
three variants and you can choose the
best ones which suits your requests now
lastly but bar is a little different
from others unlike others but just dumps
the answers at once enthusiasts call it
fast but it misses the human touch of
giving the answers in a word by word
typing minor yet similar to Bing it
manages to give you different versions
of the answers besides that but has a
decent interface and its logo shines
with multiple colors giving you the
feeling of bar processing the data to
give you a better result now let's try
to ask a few most frequently asked
questions to power chat
let's ask with a simple one are you
friends with
chat GPD and Bing
you can see The Shining logo of Bot and
you have just seen the way how Google
bot answers you it just dumps the answer
now if you go or if you ask the same
question to the other one select charge
gbd and Wing let's see how they respond
and you can see you have other drives as
well right so you can see track 1 draft
2 and draft three so you can choose any
ones which you feel are more optimized
and you know deliverable according to
your requests right now let's go back to
think right now let's ask the same
question
are you friends with
chat GPD
and but
see the word by word typing approach of
Bing and charge APD gave you a little
more immersive feeling that somebody is
really talking to you right and you also
have the freedom of
choosing the answer wisely right so it
gives you three different options which
are creative balanced and precise right
and on just one single scroll you have
the Bing search open here right this is
one other good way of using Bing in the
in case if you have any questions that
are unanswered or which did not satisfy
you you can also go back to Bing and you
can manually search for the data and get
the information right now let's get back
to chat GPD
here let's ask this in question
are you
friends with
Bing and bad
B
so that's how individual AI models
respond to each other and now let's get
back to the next point of discussion
which is what is the data or history
about the questions you asked or the
prompts you have opened that each one of
these stores
so this is about the conversation
history or the prompt that you have with
in division one of these AI models
first comes the chat GPD charge GPD
claims they do not store any data about
its interaction with its users but in
chat GPD you can access the prompts and
questions you asked you can also export
your transcripts in chat GPD on the
other hand we have bing bing says they
do not have any history or prompts of
your previous conversations as well and
lastly but but is a little mix and match
at both so what bar does is it Stores
Only the prompts whereas in chat GPT
when you ask a question it will store
the question and the onsite gave you but
but it will only store The Prompt that
is the question you asked and note the
answer it gave to you so with that the
next point of discussion would be the
mobile version of each one of these as
of now Chad gbd hasn't released any of
the official mobile application version
yet and on the other hand on Bank it has
just one click of a button and you can
click it and then Launches on your
mobile phone and when has a mobile
variant with similar and much better
Aesthetics that can get started on a
touch of an app launcher and lastly we
have Bard Bart has a similar approach to
its mobile variant Google has enabled
part usage in Google mobile application
as well and now comes the number of
questions asked disclaimer if you want
to work on a project presentation or
thesis choose your AI model wisely
because if you are close to wrapping up
your project and the AI model says sorry
pal you're out of your wishes Yes you
heard me right a few of these language
models have a limitation on the number
of questions asked on one single topic
or one single keyword or one single
concept let's look into details before
we proceed to the next part of this
video let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success and their careers hey
I'm Sharia Jaleel I live in Ontario
Canada I have been in I.T sector for the
past 20 years I recently took the
professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning the course has changed the way
I look at things and helped me back some
amazing freelance projects I started my
career in 1999 and over the years I have
worked with many companies my last tenor
was with IBM Canada my aim was to
restart my carrier and learn something
that would help accelerate my career
thought artificial intelligence can make
me Future Ready
the course in artificial intelligence
and machine learning is provided by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
courts I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome the quality of
interaction within the course was simply
amazing the course faculty was also very
experienced and knowledgeable
after the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects
also I am planning to start
an AI based startup with my friend where
I feel that the learning from the course
to be very helpful I am really delighted
and happy in my free time I try to
create meaningful content on YouTube and
I talk about new technologies and what
kind of courses professionals should be
taking along with many other topic I
definitely recommend this course to
everyone after all when it comes to new
skills to advance your career there
should be no compromise you should
always learn from the band
[Music]
first comes chat gbd chat GPD takes 25
questions on a single keyword or a
single subject or a single topic of
discussion post that it refrains from
answering your questions
same with Bing it takes no more than 20
questions on single keyword or a single
topic or a single concept
but now comes Brad
Brad is a little different Brad kind of
said this takes a little too high it
almost has no limits to your questions
you can ask any number of questions to
God and that can be a real deal breaker
lastly we will differentiate these AI
models based on their productivity yes
exactly we do know all these three
models are smart but how smart exactly
how humanly are they how close are they
in convincing you with an optimistic
answer what's their potential to charge
a hypothetical question and give you a
balanced answer sounds interesting right
let's get started first let's start with
chat GPD so let's say I want to learn Ai
and machine learning so obviously this
should be able to teach me that let's
ask it
can you
teach me
artificial intelligence
machine learning
brilliant it gave me a brief about
artificial intelligence machine learning
types of machine learning and deep
learning in one go and it also convince
you here right yes as an AI model I can
certainly help you with that right so
it's a good answer now let's try to ask
a little different one
or
can it plan an itinerary or can it buy
me a product online or can it do some
other things like booking me an Uber
right so let's try 10 new
or change
online
training program
for
Ai and ml
brilliant charge GPA knows its limits
right as an AI model I cannot directly
purchase online right it's giving you
the brutal truth here that's good and
apart from that it also gave you a
step-by-step procedure
for buying your course do your research
check the curriculum check the
instructor what's the format what's the
cost right a few parameters which you
might want to consider before buying a
course right so now let's try to
question the same queries to Wing So
since Bing and chat GPT share the same
training data set I could expect a
similar answer but let's see it is
taking a while I guess Prometheus is a
little
slower compared to GPT okay there might
be a connection issue let's ask the
question once again
wow it's way too better than charge EVD
so it is even asking you details on if
you if you are looking for a specific
topic or a general overview let's say I
would need a general overview
I could straight away say Bing is a
little more smarter and productive
compared to chat jbd but still we have
one more Contender to compare with but
right
so there might be again the internet
connection
now let's say we refresh Bing once again
and straight away ask the second
question what we had right that is can
you buy me a course
online course
for learning
artificial
thing did gave me a good answer for the
previous question let's see what kind of
an answer it gives me now I'm sorry but
I'm not capable of making online
purchases however I can find you some
online courses for learning AI would you
like me to search for some options
brilliant
so this is a little more optimized
answer compared to chat GPU search for
some online courses but again a chart
GPD gave us some parameters to consider
right so I would give or I would choose
to tie them up here they are on a tie
now our last Contender that is part
let's try to ask the same questions to
Bart so here is but now let's try to ask
questions too but let's say can you
teach me
machine learning
you can see the bad logo shining there
now it should be dumping the answer
anytime soon yeah of course we do miss
that humanly Touch of giving the answer
in a word by word typing way
let's refresh and ask the question again
can you teach me
learning
this is a little too straightforward I'm
a language model I don't have the
capacity to help you out
so
okay let's not give up here let's try to
ask the second question can you purchase
an online
training program
to me
to learn
machine learning
yes I can help you purchase an online
program for machine learning here are a
few things that you need to consider
good
it's not being brutally honest here it
is saying it can help you out so again
what I intended to expect here was you
cannot just directly buy an online
program right you need some details
credentials and everything to purchase
so again it is the answer and it is
definitely giving you suggestions
similar to chat GPD but a little
different which focuses on your learning
style level of experience your budget
good nice way to answer some questions
like this one so all these three ones
are brilliant and good in their own way
so it might be a little difficult to
declare host the winner as of now since
the bad AI model is going to switch to
Palm 2 and we are expecting some updates
to each one of these with that we can
consider currently they are standing
next to each other with similar
capabilities and better enhancement in
different fields so with that having
said we can conclude this session on
chat GPD versus Bing versus bot and if
you would like me to answer the
conclusion I would say well it seems
like we all have our strengths and
weaknesses at the end of the day it
comes to word users value the most that
they want a visually appealing interface
strong privacy protections or the
ability to converse with an AI language
model it's up to them to decide so you
are the viewers and you can decide the
winner of this particular battle on chat
gbd versus Bing versus bad and with that
having said if you are an aspiring
artificial intelligence engineer looking
for online training and certifications
from the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts so
that you have the most robust
foundations skills knowledge and what it
takes to become the best then search no
more simply launch postgraduate program
and artificial intelligence from Caltech
University in collaboration with IBM
should be your right choice for more
details use the links in the description
box below on that note we present you
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning elevate your professional
journey by enrolling in this Ai and ml
course presented through a partnership
between Purdue University and IBM hurry
up and enroll Now find the complete
course details from the link when
mentioned in the description box below
LGBT and googlebot are the two ah
chatbots you must have heard about they
bought an immense change in the way we
operate right now from web development
to digital marketing from cloud
computing to cyber security they are now
everywhere you just name it and they
have it trust me the use of these
chatbots has changed everything now if
you want to create a complete YouTube
video just ask them and rest the show
they'll take care for your task not just
that but if you want to create a search
engine optimized content whether it be
for your website or on YouTube these AI
tools can help you with such content
search engine optimization is not easy
it takes a lot to optimize your content
so that people can get to see it on top
what are these AI tools threat to people
engaged in search engine optimization in
this video we'll not discuss what these
AI tools can do for you but we'll
discuss if AI tools like chat GPT or
Google bar will take over SEO or not but
before that if you enjoy watching these
videos and find them interesting please
subscribe to our Channel because we
bring the best videos for you daily hit
the Bell icon to get notified whenever
we drop a new video the goal of SEO is
to make a website more visible and bring
in income from natural traffic it
entails crafting excellent content for a
specific audience and optimizing a
website for search engines online
marketers employ AI to accomplish
various tasks such as keyword research
content optimization and Link building
more quickly businesses can boost their
ranks and increase their revenue by
using AI in SEO strategies additionally
by automating routine processes it can
save time and resources also if you want
to master the field of search engine
optimization and digital marketing
simply learns postgraduate program in
digital marketing is clearly the right
choice for you this postgraduate program
in collaboration with Purdue will help
you master search engine optimization
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
management and optimization URL
management search psychology keyword
research Advanced ad features and more
not only these skills but you will also
learn a number of tools like SC ranking
HootSuite Google ads Keyword Planner and
much more so hurry up and find the
course Link in the description box for
more details here it from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
digital marketing through this course
I moved to the United States four years
ago to live with my family
I have a background in social media by
doing the same was difficult here
more so because my English is not that
good last year I decided to pursue the
professional certification program in
digital marketing from Purdue University
offered by simple learn
I like that it could provide such as
flexible schedule for attending the live
classes it came with a recorded feature
with a blessing for working
professionals like me tell me make
significant progress I am already using
these kids to sell my products online I
believe that I have come one step closer
to living my dream life in America so
let's talk about SEO developments with
chat GPT and Google bar and notably the
influence AI is anticipated to have on
search engines has been highlighted by
the recent launches of Google's bar and
chat Deputy assistant being although
these recent advancements pose a severe
engine they also present opportunities
for digital marketers to seize in a
world full of SEO things change all the
time and Subs are never stable the page
that a search engine displays as a
result of a user's search query is known
as the search engine result pitch or
server this is why it's important to be
able to change with the times and
benefit from from new technological
developments digital marketers
increasingly use AI for keyword research
heading ideas and content optimizations
this is so they can concentrate on the
jobs that need human interaction small
sites May produce original seo-friendly
material much more quickly with chat DPT
then they could without it for instance
however it's vital to remember that this
is only a portion of the process it can
assist you with creating and providing
meta descriptions and titles keyword
research heading recommendations for
pages and posts article ideation and
composing copy so let's talk about the
role of AI in keyword research every
business utilizes AI to increase
productivity automate labor intensive
operations and make data driven choices
numerous Industries including finance
and banking e-commerce retail media
gaming research space exploration
Transportation automative medicine
manufacturing security and uses it in
various ways the Google AdWords Keyword
Planner and the Google Trends tool are
two of the most widely used free
artificial intelligence keyword research
tools you may find keywords with a lot
of search volume and little competition
using these tools another crucial aspect
to take into account when choosing
keywords for your website is intent this
is so because users frequently have a
purpose while searching for goods and
services although it might be
challenging to ensure your website
appears high on search engine result
Pages especially with Google's algorithm
adjustments SEO companies and marketers
must constantly check their websites to
make sure that their websites are not
falling in the servers they can use AI
to automatically analyze search traffic
statistics and website content to spot
potential issues before they arise they
can then address these problems and
offer consistent organic rankings this
is a game changer for SEO companies and
marketers who realize on manual SEO
efforts to get traffic to their websites
but the main question is will charge GPT
or googlebot take over SE the answer is
clearly a big why chat Bots like chat
deputy and Bart cannot replace SEO they
can help generate content for your
website or video but SEO involves more
than just content creation it includes
tasks keyword research link building and
Technical SEO where you'll need an SEO
expert because chat Bots can't decide
how to build links and which links will
get you more organic traffic SEO is
constantly changing due to search engine
algorithms search engines like Google
and Bing regularly update their
algorithms making SEO a dynamic field
SEO requires human judgment and decision
making the end of discussion because
determining which keywords to Target and
which links to build required expertise
and human decision making a chatbot
can't do it in fact the real power of
search engine optimizations lie is not
in their mechanical abilities but in
their creativity and ability to
understand what people are searching for
and why that's something that AI
Technologies may never be able to
replicate and it's what makes human SEO
experts such a valuable asset so while
it's true that AI Technologies may
eventually be able to take over some of
the aspects of SEO there's still plenty
of rooms for human experts to thrive
whether you are a seasoned SEO
professional or just starting out here's
still a place for you in this exciting
and ever evolving field
let's keep an eye on the developments in
AI technology and see how it can augment
and enhance our skills rather than
replacing them entirely who knows with
the power of AI and human expertise
combined the future of SEO may be even
brighter than we can imagine so with
that we have come to the end of this
discussion although everyone can have
different opinions on this but I hope
you guys must have got an idea about why
these AI tools are not a threat to a c
if you still have any questions or
doubts let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will help you at the earliest here we
wrap up the full course on chair GPT
expert if you have any questions feel
free to post them in the comment section
below and share the video with your
friends and do not forget to like share
and subscribe to Simply learn to never
miss any updates from Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
profession National looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here